ung übernehmen sich eventuell
entschuldigen herzlich Willkommen zu
heute im Parlament zur Live Übertragung
der Regierungserklärung des Kanzlers wir
schauen ins Plenum und sehen die
Regierungsbank wo das Kabinett Platz
nehmen wird weiß noch große Lücken auf
doch der Bundeskanzler begrüßt schon
einige Abgeordnete im Plenum wir nutzen
die Zeit und geben ab zu meiner Kollegin
Andrea die im Plenum kurz vor dem Plenum
steht Andrea was ist den deine Erwartung
an die Rede des Kanzlers der Druck ist
ja groß dass es eine große Rede
wird ja der Druck ist groß du sagst es
ihn es gefordert wird eine Rede im Stil
der Zeitenwende durchaus wahrscheinlich
ist allerdings dass der Kanzler seiner
Methode seinem Stil treu bleibt und sich
von den Erwartungen nicht treiben lässt
er wird so höre ich sich zur Frage aller
Fragen zum Haushalt 2024 wo und wie also
diese Regierung in Zukunft Geld her
bekommen möchte dazu wird er sich nicht
äußern die Opposition hat diese Frage
zur Gretchenfrage erklärt
und da ist eben ein wichtiger Punkt der
Orientierung
in dieser schweren von seiner Regierung
verschuldeten Krise den er heute wohl
offen lassen wird und da ist die Frage
ob er tatsächlich den hohen Erwartung an
seine Rede heute hier gerecht werden
kann die Ampel ist sicher bei der Frage
wie die Finanzlöcher zu stopfen sind
nicht einig unüberbrückbar scheinen die
Gegensätze das wird auch die te heute
zeigen
oder ja es ist ja so dass bisher die
Sparvorschläge die auf dem Tisch liegen
die betreffen eben immer die
Lieblingsprojekte der anderen die Grünen
müssen um die Kindergrundsicherung
fürchten die SPD um das Bürgergeld die
FDP hat Angst davor dass es jetzt doch
Steuererhöhung geben könnte das ist die
Gemengelage das sind Unvereinbarkeiten
die bisher zusammengehalten wurden durch
diesen
Trick der der bisherigen Haushalts
Führung das hat das Verfassungsgericht
ja jetzt als verfassungswidrig erklärt
und jetzt muss eine andere Lösung her
danke Andrea für diese ersten Eindrücke
und Erwartungen Scholz der Kanzler ist
aufgerufen von der Bundestagspräsidentin
Bar er müsste jetzt jeden Moment zum
Pult gehen und dann hat er 25 Minuten
für seine Regierungserklärung zum
Haushalt zum Haushalt 23 und 24 in
diesem Jahr eine ganz besondere
Situation wir hören
rein frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen
und
Kollegen bevor ich auf das Thema unserer
heutigen Debatte eingehe möchte ich aus
aktuellem Anlass eine Sache
voranstellen in den zurückliegenden
Tagen haben die Terroristen der Hamas
endlich Geiseln freigelassen die Geiseln
ihre Freunde und Angehörigen haben in
den vergangenen Wochen unvorstellbares
durchgemacht um so Gl und auch
erleichterter bin ich dass sie nun in
Freiheit und in Sicherheit
sind das unter den freigelassenen auch
mehrere deutsche sind ist ein weiterer
Grund zur Freude allen die sich in den
zurückliegenden Tagen und Wochen für ihr
Schicksal eingesetzt haben in
unzähligigen vertraulichen Gesprächen
durch unermütliche Diplomatie sage ich
für diesen Einsatz von ganzem Herzen
Danke natürlich ist diese Freilassung
nur ein erster Schritt noch immer hält
die Hamas mehr als 100 Frauen Männer und
Kinder in ihrer Gewalt auch sie müssen
nun unverzüglich freigelassen werden die
Bundesregierung wird dazu weiter mit
ganzer Kraft
beitragen
meine Damen und Herren ich möchte hier
im Deutschen Bundestag heute erklären
wie die Regierung mit den Folgen des
jüngsten Urteils des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts umgeht das
Gericht hat sich am 15 November erstmals
sehr detailliert und sehr weitreichend
dazu geäußert wie die sogenannte
Schuldenbremse im Grundgesetz genau
anzuwenden
ist bereits zuvor gab es in derselben
Sache einen Eilantrag schon in diesem
Beschluss hielt das Gericht mit Blick
auf die Regelung zur Schuldenbremse fest
und ich zitiere dass die
Tatbestandsvoraussetzung der
maßgeblichen Verfassungsnormen in der
Rechtsprechung des Senats bislang noch
keine Konturierung erfahren haben noch
keine Konturierung das heißt vieles im
Umgang mit der Schuldenbremse war
bislang rechtlich eher nicht eindeutig
geklärt in dieser Lage haben wir vor
zwei Jahren haushaltspolitische
Einschätzung vorgenommen
verfasssgericht nun rechtlich verworfen
worden sind das Bundesverfassungsgericht
hat dadurch Klarheit geschaffen und das
Gericht hat das letzte Wort so ist es
gute demokratische
Tradition wissenschaftlich mag das
Urteil weiter diskutiert werden
politisch aber ist die Diskussion mit
dem karlsuh Richterspruch
beendet mit dem um die aktuelle
Entscheidung hätten wir im Winter 2021
andere Wege beschritten Wege die das
Gericht in seinem Urteil ebenfalls
gewiesen hat das Urteil betrifft die
haushaltspraxis dieser Regierung aber
auch früherer und künftiger Regierung
das Urteil betrifft die bisherige Praxis
des Bundes genauso wie die der vieler
Länder und nicht nur weil auch die
Länder zum Teil in ganz ähnlicher Weise
wie der Bund Sondervermögen
nutzen wir haben in den vergangenen
Tagen intensiv über die Folgen des
Urteils beraten diese Beratung sind wie
sollte es anders sein noch nicht
abgeschlossen Sorgfalt geht dabei V
Schnelligkeit klar ist dieses Urteil
schafft eine neue Realität für die
Bundesregierung und für alle
gegenwärtigen und die zukünftigen
Regierung im Bund und in den Ländern
eine Realität die es allerdings
schwieriger macht
und weitin geteilte Ziele für unser Land
zu erreichen schwierig geworden ist es
auch weil Deutschland in den vergangenen
zwei Jahren von schweren
unvorhergesehenen äußeren Krisen
erschüttert worden ist und stellt das
vor Herausforderung wie unsere Republik
sie in dieser Konzentration und Härte
wohl noch nicht erlebt
hat sfälle und
69901 Neuansteckung am Tag so lauteten
die Zahlen im Corona Tagesbericht des
RKI am 8 dezember
2021 das war der Tag des Amtsantritts
dieser
Bundesregierung unser Land befand sich
seiner Zeit mitten in der deltaw Omicron
stand bevor ganze Wissens
Wirtschaftssektoren standen mit dem
Rücken zur Wand zwei Monate später griff
Russland die Ukraine an
es gibt keinen Zweifel daran dieser
Eroberungskrieg auf europäischenem Boden
schafft auf Jahre hinaus eine vollkommen
veränderte sicherheitspolitische Lage
für Deutschland und für ganz
Europa unser Land war darauf
unzureichend vorbereitet wir haben daaus
Konsequenzen gezogen übrigens auch
gemeinsam mit ihrer Fraktion Herr märz
und dafür bin ich dankbar
Deutschland ist heute der zweitgrößte
Unterstützer der Ukraine nach den
Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika auch bei
den Waffenlieferung wir setzen diese
Unterstützung fort so lange wie nötig
unsere zivile unterstützung kommt noch
hinzu über den Bundeshaushalt und auch
über den über die Europäische Union Geld
das wir natürlich bei Regierungsantritt
und vorkriegsbeginn nicht eingeplant
hatten und doch ist diese Unterstützung
von existenzieller
Bedeutung für die Ukraine das ist klar
aber auch am Ende für uns in Europa denn
niemand von uns möchte sich ausmalen
welche noch viel gravierenderen
Konsequenzen es für uns hätte wenn Putin
diesen Krieg
gewönne mehr als milonen Ukrainer
Ukrainer Frauen Männer und Kinder sind
innerhalb weniger Wochen vor Leid und
Tod in ihrer Heimat nach Deutschland
geflohen wir haben Sie bei uns hier
aufgenommen das war
richtig das war ein Gebot der
Menschlichkeit aber natürlich bedeutet
die Aufnahme so vieler Menschen eine
enorme Anstrengung selbst für ein so
starkes Land wie
Deutschland kurz nach Kriegsbeginn hat
Putin dann die gastlieferung nach
Deutschland zunächst gedrosselt und
schließlich über Nacht komplett
eingestellt nordstream 1 und eine der
Röhren von nordstream 2 wurden gesprengt
die Pipelines also die uns in den
kommenden Jahren mit günstigem Gas
versorgen sollten Gas das meine
Amtsvorgängerin immer wieder und zurecht
als die notwendige brückenenergie für
die Energiewende bezeichnet hat mit dem
Wegfall von Lieferung aus Russland
fehlten auf dem Weltmarkt praktisch auf
von einem Tag auf den anderen 120
Milliarden kubikmer Gas wohlgemerkt bei
gleichbleibender
Nachfrage sie alle kennen die Folgen die
Marktpreise gingen durch die Decke
zwischenzeitlich hatten sie sich mehr
als
verzehnfacht und noch immer ist Gas
unsere rückenenergie mehr als doppelt so
teuer wie zu Beginn der
Energiekrise nicht spurlos vorbei an
einem Industrieland wie
Deutschland wir haben nicht nur schnell
reagiert und in Rekordzeit
flüssiggasterminals an den norddeutschen
Küsten gebaut im vergangenen Winter
2022 haben wir bis zu 20000 Milliarden
Euro bereitgestellt um den Bürgerinnen
und Bürgern und unseren Unternehmen in
dieser dramatischen Notlage die
Sicherheit zu geben die sie damit sie
zurecht
kommen
und es war richtig zu helfen denn so
haben wir Millionen Bürger und Bürgern
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern und vielen
Betrieben durch diese enorm schwierige
Zeit geholfen dabei war von Beginn an
klar es reicht nicht aus nur auf den
Winter
2022 23 zu schauen es ging immer auch um
den Winter
von dem uns nahezu alle Expertin und
Experten einhellig gesagt haben er
könneen noch kritischer werden als der
vorherige wenn wir die Mittel die 2023
für diese Hilfen nötig gewesen sind nun
noch einmal im Haushalt verankern dann
bestätigen wir lediglich was wir schon
Ende 22 beschlossen hatten was damals
nötig und richtig war und heute noch
genauso nötig und richtig
ist
die coronapandemie habe ich gerade schon
erwähnt auch hier war es nötig und
richtig dass wir noch in der
Vorgängerregierung umfangreiche
coronahilfen beschlossen haben über
mehrere Jahre hinweg auch hier ging es
um Sicherheit und um eine Perspektive
für die Bürgerin und Bürger so und nur
so ist Deutschland besser durch diese
jahrhundertpand gekommen als viele
andere
Länder es war nötig und richtig liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen dass wir
unmittelbar nach dem Beginn des
russischen angriffskriegs gegen die
Ukraine ein Sondervermögen beschlossen
haben um unsere Bundeswehr über die
kommenden Jahre hinweg zu stärken und
besser
aufzustellen und es war nötig und
richtig meine Damen und Herren dass wir
den Bürgern und Bürgern in rin F und
neutrin Westfalen den Bürgern und
Bürgern im Atal geholfen haben als ihr
Hab und Gut 2021 von den Wassermassen
zerstört
W natürlich ist der Wiederaufbau nach
solch einer Katastrophe nicht in 5
Monaten beendet so ein Wiederaufbau
oftmals von Null dauert
Jahre wir schulden es den Opfern und den
Betroffenen vor Ort dass wir ihn dabei
solidarisch zur Seite stehen so wie wir
es gemeinsam beschlossen und versprochen
haben wir wollen die Hilfen für das atil
und die energiepreishilfen daher noch
einmal im Haushalt für dieses Jahr
verankern und von der Ausnahmeregel in
Artikel 115 des Grundgesetzes Gebrauch
machen so schlagen wir es ihnen im
Zusammenhang mit dem agshaushalt 2023
vor das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat
diesen Weg in seinem Urteil ausdrücklich
gewiesen mehr noch es hat bestätigt dass
dem Gesetzgeber in außergewöhnlichen
Notsituationen wie Artikel 115 absatz 2
Satz 6 sie vorsieht ein einschätzungs
und Beurteilungsspielraum
zukommt eine neue Realität schafft das
Urteil allerdings insofern als Hilfen in
solchen Notsituationen nun jedes Jahr
vom Bundestag neu beschlossen werden
müssen aber auch neu beschlossen werden
können damit trägt das Gericht dem
Umstand Rechnung dass die üblichen
Spielräume eines regulären Haushalts in
solchen Notsituationen eben nicht
ausreichen wie also gehen wir mit dieser
Realität nun konkret
um erstens noch am Tag des Urteils hat
der Bundesfinanzminister Ausgaben aus
dem Wirtschaftsplan des Klima und
transformationsfonds gesperrt von der
Sperre ausgenommen sind Verpflichtung
die der Bund schon vertraglich
eingegangen ist ausgenommen sind
außerdem Maßnahmen die die
Energieeffizienz und den Einsatz
erneuerbare Energien im Gebäudebereich
fördern das Gebieten die
Rechtssicherheit und die Verlässlichkeit
gegenüber den Bürger und
Bürgern
mit einem Nachtragshaushalt für 2023
werden wir zudem die Rücklage des Klima
und transformationsfonds um 60
Milliarden Euro
verringern zweitens wir haben Vorsorge
getroffen damit nicht automatisch neue
finanzielle Verpflichtung für die
kommenden Jahre eingegangen werden und
zwar sol lange bis wir alle Fragen
prezise beantwortet haben die sich nach
dem Urteil
Stellen wichtig ist laufende Ausgaben
sind davon nicht betroffen der Staat
wird seinen Aufgaben auch weiterhin
gerecht ich sage das auch an die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger gerichtet die
aufgrund mancher wilder Vorschläge und
manch gezielter Falschmeldung in den
sozialen Medien verunsichert sind in
ihrem Alltag hier und heute ändert das
Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichts
nichts völlig unabhängig davon ob sie
Kindergeld oder barfk bekommen eine
Rente oder
Wohngeld
drittens wir stellen sicher dass der
laufende Haushalt 223 allen Vorgaben des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts
entsprichtcht das Kabinett hat gestern
dem Entwurf eines Nachtragshaushaltes
für 223 zugestimmt dieser wurde dem
Bundestag als Haushaltsgesetzgeber
zugeleitet zudem werden wir den
Bundestag wie schon gesagt vchlagen ein
Beschluss gemäß Artikel 115 Absatz 2 des
Grundgesetzes zu fassen ich habe es
gerade
erwähnt damit sichern wir nachträglich
die energiepreisbremsen für 2023 ab die
im Zuge des russischen angriffskriegs
gegen die Ukraine erforderlich geworden
sind das ist wichtig für die Bürgerin
und Bürger für unsere krankenhiseer und
für die Unternehmen und damit sichern
wir auch die Unterstützung für die vom
Hochwasser betroffenen Familien in
rheinlandpals Nordrhein
Westfalen wichtig ist wir stellen
dadurch die bereits vom Bundestag
bewilligtmittel zur krisenbewältung auf
eine andere Rechtsgrundlage so tragen
wir den Vorgaben des Verfassungsgerichts
Rechnung aber eben auch der Tatsache
dass die energiepreiskrise jetzt wohl
definitiv noch nicht ganz beendet ist
und die Zerstörung nach einer
Jahrhundertflut noch nicht beseit
sind dass wir die energiepreisbremsen
gleich wohl zu Beginn des kommenden
Jahres beenden können hat ein einfachen
Grund inzwischen sind überall in
Deutschland wieder Strom und Gastarife
verfügbar die zwar deutlich höher liegen
als vor der Krise aber
meist unterhalb der Obergrenzen die wir
für die preisbremsen gezogen haben und
ebenfalls spürbar unterhalb der Preise
im vergangenen Herbst und Winter unsere
gastspeicher haben wir zudem so gut
gefüllt dass wir nicht mit plötzlichen
Preissprüngen rechnen klar ist aber auch
sollten die Preise für Energie dennoch
erneut unerwartet dramatisch steigen
sind wir jeder Zeit in der Lage
kurzfristig zu
handeln viertens die Regierungsfraktion
haben vergangene Woche beschlossen über
die Auswirkung des Urteils auf den
haushal Entwurf für 2024 ausführlich zu
beraten dafür haben sie den Abschluss
der Haushaltsberatung
verschoben das gibt uns Zeit vorhandene
Spielräume im Haushalt auszuloten
Schwerpunkte zu setzen und natürlich
auch Ausgaben zu
beschränken zusammen mit dem Bundestag
arbeiten wir nun intensiv daran alle
Beschlüsse die für den Haushalt 2024 s
so schnell wie möglich zu treffen denn
die Bürger und Bürger und unsere
Unternehmen brauchen in unruhigen Zeiten
Klarheit und ganz klar
ist die Bürger und Bürger können darauf
vertrauen dass der Staat seine Zusagen
ihnen gegenüber
einhält wir lassen niemanden allein mit
den Herausforderungen mit den wir akell
das habe ich im vergangenen Jahr
versprochen und da
bleib weiß jetzt nicht wie ich ihren
Spaß da interpretieren soll aber
vielleicht ja so Walk without chrtian
Democratic Union also das ist vielleicht
kein so guter
Einfall
am Ende geht es dabei auch um etwas
Grundsätzliches nämlich um den
Zusammenhalt in unserem Land um den
Sozialstaat es geht um die Frage steht
jeder für sich allein wenn es schwierig
wird oder haken wir uns unter ich bin
zutiefst überzeugt wir alle kommen
besser zurecht wenn wir niemanden
zurücklassen
wir alle kommen besser zurecht wenn wir
uns den Herausforderung Seite an Seite
stellen klar ist auch in unserer
Unterstützung der Ukraine und bei der
Bewältigung der Energiekrise dürfen wir
auf keinen Fall nachlassen das wäre
nicht verantwortlich das würde unsere
Zukunft
gefährden und zugleich wäre es ein
schwerer ein unverzeilicher Fehler über
die Bewältigung all dieser akuten
herausford die Modernisierung unseres
Landes zu
vernachlässigen diese Modernisierung ist
nötig und richtig sie schafft die
Voraussetzung für gute Arbeitsplätze und
eine starke Wirtschaft damit das
Fundament unseres künftigigen Wohlstands
gesichert bleibt natürlich haben auch
die regierungschefinen und
Regierungschefs der Länder das
allergrößte Interesse daran dass
Zukunftsinvestitionen bei ihnen Vorort
auch zustande kommen Investitionen etwa
in
schiffindustrie im klimafreundlichen
Stahl oder
Batteriefabrik uns ein darüber hinaus
eine Überzeugung nur wenn sich
Deutschland modernisiert werden wir in
der Lage sein auch künftig auf
unvorhergesehene Krisen kraftvoll zu
reagieren meine Damen und Herren wir
haben zu Beginn unserer Regierung
entschieden nicht länger zuzusehen wie
Deutschlands Infrastruktur
verfällt und zwar klar wir müssen jetzt
kraftvoll in die Modernisierung
Deutschlands investieren wir müssen
jetzt dafür sorgen dass wir in
Deutschland die Transformation unserer
Wirtschaft hinbekommen und als starkes
Industrieland wettbewerbsfähig
bleiben und wir müsen alles daran setzen
die Energiewende in Deutschland und
Europa endlich voranzubringen die von
vielen Vorgängerregierung versprochen
wurde aber ni als wirklich
umgesetzt wir müssen jetzt den
Reformstau auflösen wir müssen jetzt
Tempo machen nach Jahren des
[Applaus]
stillstandsenielen all diesen Zielen
arbeitet die von mir geführte
Bundesregierung von Tag 1 an die großen
Modernisierungsvorhaben für unser Land
sind nicht hinfällig geworden im
Gegenteil
egal wo man hinschaut ob in die USA oder
nach Frankreich nach China oder Japan
überall sind Regionen dabei massiv in
die Zukunft zu
investieren weltweit investieren Länder
in moderne und digitale Infrastruktur in
saubere Energieversorgung und in
klimafreundliche Technologien
wir sind mitten im Aufbruch in eine neue
era vergleichbar in seiner Dimension nur
mit dem Aufbruch in das
Industriezeitalter jetzt schon in den
allernächsten Jahren entscheidet sich wo
künftig Wertschöpfung stattfindet wo
Innovation und Wohlstand zu Hause sind
in einer klimaneutralen
Welt ich will dass Deutschland ganz
vorne dabei ist denn es geht für uns
alle um viel es geht um sichere
Arbeitsplätze es geht um eine
wettbewerbsfähige Wirtschaft es geht um
ein gutes Leben für kommende Generation
und es geht um unsere Fähigkeit auch
künftige Krisen sicher zu
bewältigen mit diesen klaren Prämissen
beraten wir jetzt über den Haushalt für
das kommende Jahr mit der nötigen Ruhe
und in Verantwortung für unser Land
darauf können die Bürger und Bürger sich
verlassen dafür stehe ich als
Bundeskanzler ich danke
ihnen Kanzler Scholz mit seiner
Regierungserklärung er begründete erneut
die erneute Notlage Ausrufung einer
Notlage auch für das Jahr
2023 um auch für 23 die Schuldenbremse
erneut auszusetzen für das Jahr 2024 wo
sich ja mit Blick auf den Haushalt noch
größere Probleme auftun sagte er nichts
Konkretes außer dass er und seine
Regierung weiterhin zu den großen Zielen
den großen Projekten mit Blick auf die
den Umbau der Wirtschaft hin zur
Klimaneutralität weiterhin stehe wo
konkret gespart werden könne oder gar
solle sagte er
nicht
zusätzlich versuchte er die Bürger an
mehreren Stellen Bürger und Unternehmen
gleichermaßen zu beruhigen an ihrem
Alltag würde sich durch die
Haushaltssperre die verhängte nichts
ändern nun der Oppositionsführer
Fraktionschef der Union Friedrich
MZ
frau
Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren lassen Sie mich zunächst zu
beginnen sagen
dass wir den Dank und die Erleichterung
Teilen die Sie Herr Bundeskanzler zu
Beginn ihrer
Regierungserklärung zum Ausdruck
gebracht haben im Hinblick auf die
Freilassung wenigstens einer einiger der
Geiseln die sich in den letzten Wochen
in der Hand der
hamasterroristen in Israel befunden
haben und ich will ausdrücklich im Namen
unserer Fraktion sagen wir danken
denjenigen die aus ihrer Regierung daran
beteiligt waren dies zu erreichen
ausdrücklich herzlichen Dank an
sie meine Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir sprechen
heute so war es
jedenfalls bis zum Beginn der Rede Herr
Bundeskanzler mein Eindruck über die
Folgen der Entscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes vom
15 November das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat eine
Entscheidung getroffen die den
Haushaltsgesetzgeber im Bund und in den
Ländern in Zukunft zu einer strikten
Ausgabendisziplin
verpflichtet diese Entscheidung ist in
der Sache richtig sie kommt zum
richtigen Zeitpunkt und sie war vor
allem notwendig lassen Sie mich das hier
einmal deutlich
sagen weil darüber ein falscher Eindruck
auch in Teilen der veröffentlichten
Meinung entstanden ist wir haben über
dieses Urteil nicht
triumphiert uns ist uns ist die
Tragweite dieser Entscheidung des
Verfassungsgerichtes sehr wohl bewusst
aber Herr Bundeskanzler diese
Entscheidung ist notwendig geworden weil
ihre Regierung den Versuch unternommen
hat die Verschuldungsgrenzen des
Grundgesetzes in einer in bisher in
Deutschland nicht gekannten gerade zu
dreisten Art und Weise zu
umgehen und hier soogleich
den Behauptungen zu widersprechen die
ganz sicher von den Rednern der
Koalition hier gleich vorgetragen werden
das war weder eine Klage von uns gegen
den Klimaschutz noch gegen die
notwendigen Hilfen für die privaten
Haushalte und die Unternehmen in
Deutschland noch war sie dagegen
gerichtet was auch frühere Regierungen
schon einmal versucht haben das war eine
Klage die gegen die bereits in ihrem
Koalitionsvertrag auf riebene von jeder
bisherigen Staatspraxis abweichenden
Manipulation unserer
Verfassung notwendig geworden
war eine Vereinbarung in ihrem
Koalitionsvertrag die dem Ziel
diente zum einen dem Wunsch der FDP zu
entsprechen auf Steuererhöhungen und auf
die Aussetzung der Schuldenbremse zu
verzichten und zum anderen die
ungehemmte Subvention aller
Klimaprojekte der Bundesregierung weiter
zu ermöglichen und zum dritten die
Aufblähung des Sozialstaates für die
Sozialdemokraten zu ermöglichen diese
Quadratur des Kreises haben sie versucht
und dieses Kartenhaus ist am 15 November
2023 zusammengebrochen das war das
Ergebnis der Entscheidung von
klsruh und meine Damen und Herren der
Urheber der Urheber dieser
verfassungswidrigen Konstruktion war
kein geringerer als sie Herr
Bundeskanzler sie haben nämlich in der
Übergangszeit der früheren Regierung auf
die neue Regierung noch in ihrer
Funktion als
Bundesfinanzminister genau diese wie wir
heute nun dezidiert Wissen
verfassungswidrige Konstruktion erdacht
dazu hätte ich von ihnen
erwartet nachdem Sie nun
eine eine solche Niederlage vor dem
Verfassung Gericht haben einstecken
müssen übrigens schon die zweite in
wenigen Wochen dazu hätten wir erwartet
dass es wenigstens mal ein Wort des
Bedauerns von ihm gegeben hätte wenn
nicht auch ein Wort der Entschuldigung
hier angebracht gewesen wäre Herr
Bundeskanzler sie wissen doch sonst
immer alles vor allem wissen Sie immer
alles besser als alle anderen sie haben
hier eben die 41 Seiten die haben h eben
die Vorentscheidung zitiert ist ihnen
aus dieser Vorentscheidung nicht
aufgefallen welche konkreten drei Punkte
das Bundesverfassungsgericht genannt hat
für die Hauptsache Entscheidung die dann
anschließend genauso gefolgt ist wie
eine ganze Reihe von Fachleuten der
Bundesrat ihre Mitglieder in der
Bundesregierung doch teilweise auch
ihnen vorausgesagt haben sie hätten es
wissen können was das
bundesverfassungsricht am 15 November
2023 entscheidet Absturz eines
besserwissers nennt das der Spiegel in
seiner Titelgeschichte in dieser Woche
und besser hätte es gar nicht
beschrieben werden
können nun will ich nicht nur hier
Kritik üben heute morgen sondern ich
will mich weil es gerade von ihnen so
viel Zwischenrufe gibt ich will mich bei
einem Mitglied der Bundesregierung auch
einmal ausdrücklich und sehr herzlich
bedanken das ist der Vizekanzler Herr
habbeck sie haben es für richtig
gehalten bei ihrem Parteitag in der
letzten Woche meine Partei die CDU als
eine Partei aus den 90er Jahren zu
bezeichnen damit habe ich gerechnet dass
das bei ihnen kommt vielen Dank ich
empfinde es nämlich wirklich als ein
großes Kompliment was sie da gesagt
haben wir hatten nämlich wir hatten in
den 90er Jahren Wirtschaftsminister auf
der Regierungsbank sitzen die wirklich
etwas von Wirtschaftspolitik verstanden
haben wir
hatten wir
hatten wir hatten
Außenminister wir hatten Außenminister
auf der Regierungsbank sitzen die nicht
mit erhobenem Zeigefinger durch die Welt
gereist sind die überall hoch anerkannt
waren und von denen kein einziger auf
den Gedanken gekommen wäre sich bei
einer israelresolution den Vereinten
Nationen für Deutschland der Stimme zu
enthalten W kein einziger auf die Idee
gekommen und wir hatten wir hatten einen
Finanzminister wir hatten einen
Finanzminister Theo Weigel der in 10
Jahren trotz größter fiskalischer
Herausforderungen Deutschland sicher in
die Währungsunion geführt hat und Herr
Bundeskanzler wir hatten mit Helmut Kohl
einen Bundeskanzler auf der
Regierungsbank sitzen der mit der
deutschen Einheit mit dem europäischen
Binnenmarkt und mit der Währungsunion
wirklich Geschichte für Deutschland und
Europa geschrieben hat davon sind sie
doch Lichtjahre entfernt insbesondere
mit der Regierungserklärung die sie
heute morgen hier abgegeben
haben nun kann man ja vom Rednerpult aus
nicht immer die Regierung jeden Tag und
jede Minute hier anschauen aber wenn sie
mal gesehen hätten wie ihre Regierung
hier welchen Gesichtsausdruck ihre
Regierung bei ihrer Regierungserklärung
hatte meine Damen und Herren das ist
jetzt heute
volkswischa der wel es ist ein es ist
einf nur noinlich was wir von ihnen hier
sehen und
hören
Bundeskanzler Bundeskanzler sie haben
sie haben im Februar des letzten Jahres
von dieser Stelle aus eine viel
beachtete Regierungserklärung abgegeben
mit dem Wort Zeitenwende dieses Wort
findet in ihr
regierlär he ke Erwähnung mehr was sie
hier vorgetragen haben sind doch rein
technische Antworten auf eine
hochpolitische Entscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes sie sind ein
klemtner der macht ihnen fehlt jede
Vorstellung davon wie dieses Land sich
in den nächsten Jahren weiterentwickeln
soll sie haben keine Ahnung von dem was
da in den nächsten Jahren auf sie und
auf uns zukomm es tut mir herzlich leid
aber
ich muss es nach dieser
Regierungserklärung einmal so deutlich
sagen ich will es nicht überstrapazieren
und will ihnen nicht zu viele Vergleiche
zumuten aber verglichen allein mit den
Kanzlern die ihre einstmals so stolze
Partei die SPD hier in Deutschland
gestellt hat verglichen mit Willi Brand
verglichen mit Helmut Schmidt sogar mit
sogar mit Gerhard Schröder muss man doch
spätestens nach dieser
Regierungserklärung von heute morgen zu
dem Schluss kommen sie können es nicht
die Schuhe Herr Bundeskanzler die Schuhe
in denen sie
stehen die Schuhe in denen sie stehen
als Bundeskanzler der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland die sind ihnen mindestens
zwei schuhnummern zu groß anders kann
man es nicht sagen nachdem was wir heute
morgen hier von ihnen gehört
haben die Lage unseres Landes ist zu
ernst als dass wir daran nun Freude
haben könnten sie gefährden mit ihrer
Politik den Wohlstand und die Zukunft
unseres Landes vor allem die Zukunft
unserer Kinder und Enkelkinder wir
müssen möglicherweise damit rechnen dass
sie nach den letzten Turbulenzen in
ihrer Koalition der letzten zwei Woche
jetzt noch versuchen zwei Jahre über
Wasser zu bleiben und die Streit rein
und die Konflikte in ihrer Koalition
einfach so weitergehen und damit die
nachfolgenden Redner der Koalition hier
sofort die Antwort von mir bekommen sie
werden uns wieder an unsere
staatspolitische Verantwortung erinnern
die wir in diesem Lande tragen ja das
werden sie ja tun so ich will ih ich
will ihn meine Damen und Herren ich will
ihn die Antwort geben was wir als
staatspolitische Verantwortung unserer
Fraktion empfinden die wichtigste ist
ihnen auf die Finger zu schauen und wan
immer dies notwendig ist dafür zu sorgen
dass sie jedenfalls mit den uns zur
Verfügung stehenden Mitteln dazu ungen
werden unsere Verfassung einzuhalten das
ist zunächst einmal das
allerwichtigste und nur damit
sie und damit sie nicht wieder damit sie
nicht wieder überrascht sind was dann
möglicherweise das
bundesverfassungsgricht später
entscheidet will ich Sie daran erinnern
dass noch fünf Verfahren vor dem
Bundesverfassungsgericht gegen ihre
Regierung anhängig sind zur Wahlprüfung
hier in Berlin zum heizungsgesetzung zum
heizungsgesetz zur Verkürzung der
informations und auskunftpflichten des
Parlaments zur verweig eines
Untersuchungsausschusses in Sachen
scholz-wburg ein einmaliger Vorgang in
der Parlamentsgeschichte das
Minderheitenrechte des Parlamentes so
missachtet werden wie von ihnen und
schließlich gegen die Manipulation des
Wahlrechts darauf können Sie sich
einstellen für die nächsten Wochen und
Monate weitere Entscheidungen des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes legen Sie
sich diese Liste ganz oben auf Ihren
Schreibtisch damit sie nicht vergessen
was das Bundesverfassungsgericht noch zu
entscheiden hat in den nächsten
Wochen
unsere
unsere staatspolitische Verantwortung
besteht außerdem darin Ihnen immer dann
wenn wir es in der Sache für richtig
halten zuzustimmen und an den Gesetzen
unseres Landes konstruktiv mitzuwirken
das haben wir in den letzten zwei Jahren
getan ja meine Damen und Herren es ist
ihnen möglicherweise entgangen mich
hat's auch etwas überrascht aber wir
haben mehr als der Hälfte der Gesetze
ihrer Koalition im Deutschen Bundestag
zugestimmt manchem vielleicht hätten wir
gar nicht zustimmen sollen wir haben es
getan aus Überzeugung weil auch
Kompromisse notwendig sein müssen hier
im Parlament unsere staatspolitische
Verantwortung unsere staatspolitische
Verantwortung meine Damen und Herren
besteht auch darin vorschlagchläge zu
machen wie wir wieder auf einen Weg
zurückkehren können mit
umweltverträglichem Wachstum und hoher
Beschäftigung ohne dabei unsere
Staatshaushalte zu ruinieren und damit
Sie sich bitte keine Illusionen machen
damit Sie sich bitte keine Illusionen
machen wir werden an der Schuldenbremse
des Grundgesetzes festhalten und
versuchen Sie erst gar nicht versuchen
Sie erst gar
nicht versuchen Sie erst gar nicht einen
Keil in die Union zu treiben wir
versuchen Sie es erst gar nicht
versuchen Sie es nicht meine Damen und
Herren die Entscheidungen werden hier im
Deutschen Bundestag getroffen und nicht
im Rathaus von Berlin wir entscheiden
hier
darübero wir entscheiden hier darüber
und wir reden und meine Damen und Herren
wir reden nicht nur wir reden nicht nur
über Nachhaltigkeit in der Umweltpolitik
wir reden auch über Nachhaltigkeit in
den Staatsfinanzen und wir werden ihnen
nicht die Hand dazu reichen wieder
zurückzufallen in die alten
sozialdemokratischen Muster einer stetig
steigenden Staatsverschuldung und
übrigens an dieser Stelle Herr
Bundeskanzler
übrigens an dieser Stelle her
Bundeskanzler da stehen in den nächsten
Tagen da stehen in den
da stehen in den nächsten Tagen in
Brüssel einige Entscheidungen zur
Wirtschafts- und Währungsunion und zur
Fortsetzung des stabilitäts- und
wachstumspaktes an wir müssen ihnen
dabei helfen dass auch Deutschland ein
klares Signal der stabilen
Staatsfinanzen in der Währungsunion
kommt wenn in Deutschland die Dämme
brechen werden sie auch in allen anderen
Ländern der Währungsunion nicht halten
da hat Deutschland eine Vorbildfunktion
und die müssen sie ob sie wollen oder
nicht auch
wahrnehmen und dann sage ich Ihnen sehr
konkret dann sage ich Ihnen sehr konkret
zu den Themen wo wir Ihnen anbieten
etwas besser zu machen wenn Sie Ihre
wirtschaftsenergie und Umweltpolitik neu
ausrichten wollen mit wirklicher
Technologie Offenheit und mit
marktwirtschaftlichen Instrumenten wie
ja ich weiß bei diesem Wort reagieren
sie sofort allergisch Marktwirtschaft
verstehen sie überhaupt nicht können sie
nicht mehr schreiben geschweige denn
auch wirklich
heren wen sieen statt der staatlichen
Steuerung undven aller
Transformationsprozesse dann haben sie
uns an Ihrer Seite wenn Sie
Arbeitsmarktpolitik ändern wollen mit
dem Ziel einer mit dem Ziel einer
vernünftigen Balance zwischen fördern
und fordern wenn Sie wollen dass sich
Beschäftigung im Arbeitsmarkt immer und
grundsätzlich mehr lohnt als der Bezug
von Transferleistungen dann haben sie
uns an ihrer
Seite und wenn Sie darauf verzichten
wollen unter der Überschrift der
Kindergrundsicherung zunächst einmal
5000 neue Stellen im öffentlichen Dienst
zu schaffen wenn Sie darauf verzichten
wollen der Bundeskanzler dann haben sie
uns an ihrer Seite und wenn sie
überhaupt einmal aufhören dieses Land
bis mit einer bisher nie gekannten
Bürokratie zu überziehen dann haben sie
uns an ihrer se und her Bundeskanzler
wenn Sie mit uns reden wollen wie wir
das gegebenenfalls gemeinsam auf den Weg
bringen dann kommen Sie gern zu mir und
dann können wir über fast alles
miteinander reden aber wenn sie aber
wenn sie mit ihrer Regierung so
weitermachen wie bisher und ihre
Regierungserklärung von heute Morgen
gibt einen das sichere Gefühl dass sie
keinerlei Veränderungen an dem vornehmen
wollen was sie in ihrer recht Haberei in
den letzten Wochen und Monaten hier
gesagt und getan haben wenn sie weiter
uneinsichtig sind wenn sie weiter
streiten wenn sie weiter unsere
Staatsfinanzen gefährden und unsere
Volkswirtschaft vor die Wand fahren dann
werden wir alles dafür tun dass der Spuk
mit ihrer Bundesregierung so schnell wie
möglich beendet wird meine Damen und
Herren das ist die staatspolitische
Verantwortung der Opposition in diesem
Deutschen Bundestag mit ihrer
Bundesregierung Herr Bundeskanzler der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland
Friedrich märz von der Union der
Oppositionsführer mit einer aggressiven
von heme geprägten Replik auf die
Regierungserklärung des Kanzlers er
zeigte sich enttäuscht dass Scholz kein
Wort des Bedauerns geäußert hat auch
keine Entschuldigung er nannte ihn einen
Klempner der Macht dem die Schuhe zu
groß sein die Schuhe des Kanzlers das
klang nicht unbedingt nach
Handreichung der Union in Richtung KL
nicht nach einer großen Koalition auch
nicht nach einer temporären der in den
vergangenen Tagen und Wochen bereits
ansatzweise diskutiert worden
war es folgt nun Katharina dröge
kraktionschefin der Grünen ich denke von
ihr werden wir nun ganz andere Ansätze
hören wie den deralt
zu stemmen sein könnte ich denke sie
wird
erneut betonen dass man von
Investitionen von den geplanten Zielen
vom Umbau der Wirtschaft nicht abrücken
wird Liebe liebe Kolleginnen
[Musik]
Kollegen Applaus ist immer gut für alle
und
jetzt jetzt fahren wir weiter in der
Debatte und als nächst hat das Wort für
die Fraktion Bündnis 90 dieund Katharina
dröge ja selten hat die Union meine Rede
so begeistert
angekündigt aber im Ernst sehr geehrte
Frau Präsidentin Liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen sehr geehrter Herr März sie
hätten heute eine Chance gehabt sie
hätten eine Chance
gehabt sich hier als Mann darzustellen
der vielleicht auch irgendwann einmal
wieder Verantwortung in diesem Land
tragen möchte sie hätten eine Chance
gehabt eine Rede zu halten die der Lage
angemessen gewesen wäre und ich frage
mich warum gelingt ihnen das eigentlich
nie warum schffen sie es
nicht Situation wie dieser nicht einmal
den Eindruck zu erwecken dass die
Menschen in diesem Land und dass die
Unternehmen die sich gerade um ihre
Zukunft sorgen dass die ihn wichtiger
sind dass sie sich mit den ernsthafter
beschäftigen als mit parteitaktischen
hin und her und billigen Punkten für die
Union warum schaffen sie das
nicht die Realität die sieht nämlich
folgendermaßen aus
7 38 Milliarden Dollar 738 Milliarden
Dollar das ist das was die USA
investieren um die amerikanische
Wirtschaft nach vorne zu bringen um mit
Klimaschutz neue Jobs zu schaffen
738 Milliarden Dollar das ist eine Zahl
die aus meiner Sicht eins deutlich macht
wer hier nicht mitspielt verliert wer
nicht bereit ist in relevanter
Größenordnung einzusteigen bei
Investitionen in grüne Technologien bei
Investitionen in Infrastruktur die die
Zukunft bringen der wird im Wettbewerb
zwischen den größten Wirtschaftsräumen
der Welt gnadenlos verlieren und ehrlich
gesagt das sollte niemand wollen ich
kann zumindest für diese Koalition sagen
wir wollen das explizit nicht wir wollen
das Unternehmen Jobs in Deutschland
schaffen wenn sie batteriefabriken
investieren oder in die Chipproduktion
wir wollen das Unternehmen
Energieeffizienz investieren weil sie
was fürs Klima bringen aber weil sie den
Unternehmen eben auch Kosten sparen wir
wollen das Unternehmen den Sprung wagen
in neue Technologien Stahl erzeugt mit
grünem Wasserstoff Zement produziert mit
deutlich weniger CO2 wir wollen dass
Solarmodule wieder in Sachsen
hergestellt werden und deswegen ist es
notwendig dass wir hier weiter
investieren und dass wir die Wirtschaft
an dieser Stelle
unterstützen und ich bin wirklich froh
dass es dafür mittlerweile auch breite
Unterstützung gibt alle
Wirtschaftsminister vom Bund und in
allen Bundesländern gemeinsam jeder
politischen Farbe haben sich gestern
gemeinsam dafür ausgesprochen dass die
Investitionen im Klima und
Transformation fortgesetzt werden können
so sieht das nämlich aus wenn die CDU
irgendwo Verantwortung trägt dann
erkennt sie auch die Realität uns geht
es um die Zukunft des
Wirtschaftsstandortes Deutschland uns
geht es darum dass unsere Unternehmen
international wettbewerbsfähig sind uns
geht es darum 100tausende Arbeitsplätze
in diesem Land zukunftsfähig zu erhalten
und deshalb ist es keine gute Nachricht
und es kann auch keine gute Nachricht
aus Sicht einer Oppositionsfraktion sein
auch nicht aus Sicht der CDU wenn nach
dem Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes 60 Milliarden
Euro im Klima und transformationsfond
nicht mehr genutzt werden können und
dann kann man sich hier nicht so
schulterzuckend hinstellen und sagen ist
mir doch egal wenn diese Investitionen
nicht mehr möglich sind ist mir doch
egal wenn die Wirtschaft dann eine
Wirtschaftskrise rutscht das Geld ist
eben weg sie haben hier mit ihrem
Gelächter ziemlich deutlich gemacht dass
ihnen das Schicksal von Unternehmen die
sich gerade Sorgen um diese Zukunft
machen dass ih das Schicksal von
Beschäftigten in diesem Land die
Antworten brauchen ehrlich gesagt
ziemlich egal sind sie finden das ja
sogar
lustig und ich muss Ihnen
sagen ich werfe ihnen nicht vor dass sie
geklagt haben ich werfe ihnen nicht vor
dass sie geklagt haben es ist das gute
Recht einer Opposition Gesetze auch
welche die sie selbst in ähnliche Art
und Weise gemacht haben das ist hier
egal Gesetze in karlsro überprüfen zu
lassen das werfe ich ihnen nicht vor und
ich sage auch ganz deutlich das Urteil
aus karlsr das ist son klar das ist hart
das ist klar das ist eindeutig so wie
wir den Nachtragshaushalt 2021 gebucht
haben so ging es offensichtlich nicht
das haben wir als Regierung gemeinsam
falsch eingeschätzt und das bedauern wir
das kann ich ganz klar sagen das war für
niemanden gut dass wir das falsch
eingeschätzt haben und das räumen wir
jetzt auf das ist die Verantwortung der
wir uns stellen Schritt für
Schritt das erste was wir machen ist der
Nachtragshaushalt 2023 wir schaffen
Sicherheit Sicherheit für die Menschen
die angewiesen waren in einer
Energiekrise auf Gas und
strompreisbremsen mit denen wir in einem
schwierigen Winter im letzten und in
diesem bezahlbare Energiepreise
garantiert haben und das ist wichtig wir
schaffen auch jetzt den Prozess für den
Haushalt 2024 und ja das gebe ich auch
ganz unumwunden zu da liegt in dieser
Koalition noch ein Stück Arbeit vor uns
da müssen wir uns noch darauf
verständigen weil das Urteil von karlsr
nicht einfach war weil der wir ich auch
nicht leicht ist das jetzt zu
realisieren aber wir haben ganz klar
miteinander gesagt wir als
koalitionsfraktion wir verhandeln das
Miteinander wir werden Lösung finden wir
werden das zügig umsetzen und mit der
notwendigen Sorgfalt darauf können sich
die Menschen in diesem Land verlassen
und sie März sie haben jetzt in ihrer
Rede vor allen Dingen gesagt was mit
ihnen alles nicht geht und das finde ich
sehr bedauerlich und deswegen muss ich
noch mal positiv anerkennen es gibt zum
Glück nicht nur eine Union es gibt zum
Glücklich auch noch eine Union die in
Bundesländern Verantwortung trägt die
weiß wie es sich anfühlt wenn man ein
Land regiert die
wenn man vor den Unternehmen steht und
ih sagt wie geht es weiter und diese
Union die hat zum Glück auch
konstruktive Vorschläge gemacht Herr
Wegner Herr kretschm Herr Haselhoff Herr
wüst die alle haben Vorschläge gemacht
die wir sehr ernsthaft miteinander
diskutieren können das begrüße ich
ausdrücklich wenn die Ministerpräsident
der UN sagen Sieten eine modisier Sch
dann kann ich für mich sagen ich finde
das nachvollziehbar denn die
Schuldenbremse so wie sie handwerklich
damals auch von ihnen ausgestaltet wurde
die führt nicht dazu dass wir weniger
Schulden machen die führt im Endeffekt
nur dazu dass wir schulden in der
sinnlosesten aller möglichen Formen
machen wenn
wir wenn wir künftigen Generationen
kaputte Autobahnbrücken hinterlassen
dann hinterlassen wir Ihnen auch
Schulden denn künftige Nation können
diese Brücken in Zukunft ja nicht alle
zusammenbrechen lassen das würde in
Deutschland einen Verkehrskollaps herauf
beseschwören den niemand wollen kann
deswegen zukünftige Generationen werden
trotzdem investieren müssen nur dann
wird's eben teurer weil wir zu spät
gehandelt haben dann wird komplizierter
dann gibt es mehr Ärger und deswegen ist
das die sinnloseste Form von
Verschuldung die man sich ausdenken kann
und generationerecht ist daran gar
nichts man kann auch andere Vorschläge
diskutier Daniel Günther in
schlwig-holstein ist mit seiner
Regierung einen Weg gegangen er hat
jetzt gesagt krisenbedingt erklären wir
die Notlage auch noch mal für den
Haushalt
2024 und ja der Krieg in der Ukraine der
Krieg von Russland dauert an und er wird
sogar schlimmer und deswegen ist es
wichtig dass wir all unsere Anstrengung
weiterhin darauf konzentrieren die
Ukraine zu unterstützen mit Waffen mit
humanitärer Hilfe und dass wir hier
unsere Anstrengung eher noch verstärken
wir darin nachlassen und deswegen finde
ich es sinnvoll dass Daniel Günther
gesagt hat lasst uns alles offen prüfen
auch diesen Weg und jetzt komme ich zu
dem was sie vorgeschlagen Herr märz und
da fehlt es mir wirklich an
Ernsthaftigkeit und ein Stück weit auch
an Anstand das ausgerechnet von ihnen
als allererster Vorschlag kam bei der
Bekämpfung von Kinderarmut kürzen zu
wollen das finde ich wirklich schäbig
ausgerechnet be der Bekämpfung von
Kinderarmut ich hätte gedacht es wäre
Konsens unter demokratischen Parteien
dass wir alle dafür verpflichtet sind
das bestmöglichste Aufwachsen von
Kindern in diesem Land zu garantieren
ausgerechnet bei den Schwächsten in
dieser Gesellschaft als erstes zu kürzen
ausgerechnet bei denjenigen die wir am
meisten schützen müssen und die wir am
meisten unterstützen zu müssen dass das
der allererste Vorschlag ist der ihnen
eingefallen ist hier zu kürzen da haben
sie komplett den komp
verloren und eine zweite bitte hören Sie
auf mit dem Bürgergeld zu zündeln sie
wissen selber das ist ein Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes gibt das uns
aufgetragen hat dass wir Menschen im
Bürgergeld ein menschenwürdiges
Existenzminimum garantieren müssen ich
persönlich finde das in der Sache auch
absolut richtig politisch und moralisch
aber selbst wenn sie das nicht teilen
selbst wenn sie das aus irgendwelchen
Gründen nicht richtig finden Menschen
ein menschenwürdiges Existenzminimum zu
garantieren dann müssen sie anerkennen
dass das nicht gilt dann müssen sie
anerkennen dass das auch ein Grund war
warum wir das Bürgergeld im letzten Jahr
gemeinsam reformiert haben und sie im
übrigen zugestimmt haben weil uns das
Bundesverfassungsgericht das aufgetragen
hat und Redlichkeit in der Politik
bedeutet dass man sich nicht nur ein
Urteil aussucht das einem gefällt weil
man damit gerade mal ein der
Bundesregierung Probleme machen kann
redigkeit in der Politik B deeutet dann
dass man jedes Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts ernst nimmt
das zum Bürgergeld das zum Klimaschutz
und das zum Haushalt dann ist man eine
ernsthafte
rechtsstaatspartei wir haben diesen
Anspruch wir machen ernsthafte Politik
für dieses Land und ich kann sie
wirklich nur einladen nehmen Sie alle
Urteile Ernst
danke
kraktionschefin der Grünen Katharina
dröge ebenfalls mit einer sehr
emotionsgeladenen Rede sie verteidigte
die geplanten Investitionen der Ampel
die in den Umbau der Wirtschaft hinzum
mehr Klimaneutralität gehen soll als
Beispiel als Vorbild wenn man so will
führte sie schleswig- Holsteins Daniel
Günther an der nun für
Schleswig-Holstein erneut eine Notlage
ausgerufen hat um erneut die
Schuldenbremse auszusetzen es folgt hier
im Bundestag Alice Weidel von der
AFD
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Bundeskanzler sehr geehrte
Damen und
Herren keine zwei Jahre Ampel und
Deutschland steckt in der Dauerkrise und
steht am Rand der
Zahlungsunfähigkeit dieser
Verfassungsbruch ist beispiellos in der
Geschichte Deutschlands beispos ihrer
Dummheit
die Bürger
haben in dieser Lage nicht auf ihre
Regierungserklärung gewartet herr Scholz
sondern auf ihre
Rücktrittserklärung zwei Drittel der
Deutschen wollen dass diese Ampel
endlich ein Ende nimmt dass diese
Regierung immer noch im Amt ist zeigt
ihre Missachtung für den souveränen den
Bürger sie haben genug von einem
Kanzler sich mit angeblichen
Gedächtnislücken aus seiner Verstrickung
in ein der größten
steuerbetrugsskandale der Republik
herauswinden will Beweismittel
verschwinden sie haben genug von einem
ökonomischen Analphabeten als
Wirtschaftsminister der die Wirtschaft
zu Grunde richtet und die
bürgerüberheizungsdiktate
ignet sie haben genug von einer
Außenministerin die 100000 € im Jahr für
styiling ausgibt aber von einem Diplom
disaster ins nächste stolpert sie haben
genug das ist wunderbar dass sie wieder
aus der FDP dar rausbrüllen sie haben
nämlich auch genug von einem FDP
Finanzminister der verfassungswidrige
Haushalte verabschiedet um dieses grüne
Narrenschiff mitzufinanzieren und der
die Schuldenbremse abschaffen
will und sie haben genug von einer
Innenministerin die selbst das größte
Sicherheitsrisiko ist weil sie die
Grenzen und die Bürger nicht schützen
will diese Koalition regiert gegen die
Vernunft gegen die Wirklichkeit gegen
den Willen und das Wohl der Bürger und
sie regiert gegen unsere
Verfassung wir stecken in der tiefsten
Wirtschaftskrise seit es die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland gibt die
Deindustrialisierung ist
ein insolvent tunami nach dem anderen
rollt über unser
Land das ist ihr Werk das ist ihr Werk
ihres
planwirtschaftsministers und ihrer
hochsventionierten Energiewende und
Klimapolitik sie verteuern
Energie durch
Staatseingriffe verteilen dann
subvension an Teile der Industrie
während sie den Mittelstand mit
horrenden Energiepreisen hängen lassen
und über CO2 Abgabe und
transportmauterhöhung zusätzlich die
Preise noch erhöhen diese
interventionsspirale führt direkt in die
Verarmung
Unternehmen Normalverdiener und Rentner
bluten für ihre
Transformation sie brechen selbst ihr
Versprechen die Mehrwertsteuer für die
Gastronomie nicht wieder anzuheben damit
geben sie dem Gastgewerbe den to
ihr Bürgergeld treibt die sozialkrise
auf die Spitze die fleißigen werden
bestraft kein Wunder dass in ganzen
Branchen wertvolle Arbeitskräfte aus der
Steuer und abgabenspirale in das
Bürgergeld flüchten wer arbeitet ist der
Dumme wer arbeitet ist der dumme und
legt nicht mehr für sich und die Seinen
den Rücken krummen sondern für
Abkassierer aus aller
Welt
60% der Familien im bürgergeldbezug
haben keinen deutschen Pass ihr
Bürgergeld ist ein
Etikettenschwindel es ist ein
migrantengeld ein
einwanderungsmagnet die
migrationskrise bringt unser Land an den
Rand des
Zusammenbruchs fast eine halbe Million
sozialmigranten allein dieses Jahr
rechnet man die asylerstanträge und den
Familiennachzug zusammen das kostet uns
nach den offiziellen zahlen 50
Milliarden Euro jährlich sie bringen
diese Menschenmassen in Luxushotels
unter und Quartieren sie in Altenheime
ein während die Normalverdiener und
Rentner kaum noch über ihre Runden
kommen und trotzdem lassen sie die Tore
sperangelwald offen und glauben sie
können das Volk durch wirkungslosen
Aktionismus noch einmal ruhig stellen
die Bürger aber spüren am eigenen Leib
dass die unkontrollierte
Masseneinwanderung in eine umfassende
sicherheitskrise geführt hat viermal
mehr Deutsche als Zuwanderer werden
Opfer von tötungsgewalt und
Rohheitsdelikten als umgekehrt die
Gewaltkriminalität explodiert die Zahl
der ausländischen Straftäter auch für
Frauen ist der öffentliche Raum zum
Risikogebiet geworden dass sie lieber
meiden
mehr als zwei brutale Gruppen
Vergewaltigung am Tag verzeichnet die
Kriminalstatistik was haben sie da auf
unser Volk losgelassen für den Verfall
der inneren
Sicherheit tragen sie von der CDU und
CSU genauso die
Verantwortung und auf einmal empören Sie
sich über importierten islamischen
Judenhass alsten sie eben erst merkt
dass es den gibt sie haben
hunderttausende junge Männer ins Land
geholt die in judenfeindlichen
gewaltbereiten Kulturen sozialisiert
sind sie lassen zu dass
fundamentalistische
Islamverbände einen Staat im Staate
bilden die Verantwortung für wachsenen
Antisemitismus haben sie mit Fake
Statistiken der einheimischen
Bevölkerung zugeschrieben ihr
plötzlicher Aktionismus ist heuchlerisch
solange sie weiter über den alltäglichen
deutschen feindlichen alltagsterror
gegen die einheimische Bevölkerung
schweigen die Krise ist längst eine
umfassende manifeste Vertrauenskrise
geworden ihre Politik delegitimiert die
demokratischen Institution in den Augen
der redlichen Bürger sie tun so als
hätte es das vernichtende Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes überhaupt gar
nicht gegeben sie wollen auf diesen ver
gleich den nächsten Folgen lassen aber
sie haben gar kein Milliardenloch das
ist lächerlich es ist absurd in
Anbetracht eine Rekord
gesamtsteuereinnahme von einer Billion
Euro das muss man sich mal vorstellen 1
Billionen Euro das heißt sie haben nicht
zu wenig sie haben
rekordgesamtsteuereinnahmen mit denen
sie gar nicht umgehen können wie alle
Sozialisten der Weg aus der Krise führt
über die Rückkehr zur Vernunft stoppen
Sie die Massenmigration indem sie die
Grenzen schließen und
einwanderungsmagneten wie Bürgergeld
Kindergrundsicherung passverramschung
und Aufenthalt für alle abschalten lösen
Sie die klimafond auf und beenden Sie
das Milliardengrab Energie und
mobilitätswende es ist so einfach
verzichten Sie darauf sich Milliarden in
alle Welt zu verteilen für ideologische
Entwicklungshilfe Klimaschutz in Indien
und auch für die Ukraine reduzieren Sie
die Zahlung an die EU und setzen Sie
sich für eine freiheitliche Reform der
europäischen Staatengemeinschaft ein
dann bleibt auch Geld für die Lösung der
dringenden Probleme in unserem Land
Senkung der Steuern und Abgaben
Förderung von Familien sichere Renten
Sanierung des Gesundheitssystems
Wohnungsbau bessere Schulen sichere
Innenstädte und Grenzen und eine
funktionierende Armee sie aber riskieren
steuerkollaps Chaos und den
Staatsbankrott und darum brauchen wir
eine neue Regierung um aus diesem
krisensumpft herauszukommen darum
öffnen Sie den Weg für neueewahlen und
erlösen Sie dieses Land von der
ampelregierung ich bedanke mich Alis
Weidel von der AFD die zum Schluss ihrer
Rede zu Neuwahlen die Ampel zu Neuwahlen
aufgefordert hat zuvor eine rund
Umschlag gegen die
Regierungskoalition unter anderem
versuchte sie eine Kluft zu treiben
einen Keil zu treiben zwischen FDP und
Grüne indem sie dem FDP Finanzminister
vorwf er würde mit einem
verfassungswidrigen hausalt grüne
Projekte finanzieren eigene
Sparvorschläge hatte sie auch
beispielsweise bei der Migration könnte
man sparen aber auch beim
Bürgergeld und wir hören rein es gibt
einen Ordnungsruf für die gerade gehörte
Rede deshalb leider weil ich es ungerne
mache ordnungsrufe zu verteilen das mir
schön wäre wenn alle wenn alle sich in
der Sache streiten aber auf persönliche
Angriffe
verzichten und jetzt hat das Wort für
die FDP Fraktion Christian
d
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin verehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen hochverehrter
Kollege März ich war ob Teil ihrer Rede
etwas überrascht sie haben ja den
Bundeswirtschaftsminister vom glaube
grünen Parteitag zitiert mit dem Hinweis
die Union sei in den 90er Jahren stecken
geblieben ich teile die Auffassung des
Wirtschaftsministers aber darauf will
ich gar nicht hinaus sie haben sich
darauf
die wirschaftsminister der 90er ja
sozusagen ganz großartig gewesen sein
und ich will sie einfach nur darauf
hinweisen ein Wikipedia Nachschlag hätte
ausgereicht um festzustellen dass nicht
ein einziger Wirtschaftsminister der
90er Jahre von der CDU CSU gestellt
worden ist sonder ausschließlich von FDP
und SPD Liebe Kolleg Kollegen
ausschließlichhmen kann sich
weiterentwickeln man kann sich
weiterentwickeln hochvererehr Herz und
eins ist richtig der Bundeskanzler hat
es gerade gesagt das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat mit seinem
Urteil Klarheit über die Ausnahmen von
der Schuldenbremse und von
Sondervermögen geschaffen es hat im Kern
die Schuldenbremse im Grundgesetz
gestärkt und ich will deutlich sagen das
Urteil anders als es ihre Rede als ihre
Rede den Eindruck erweckt hat das Urteil
hat nicht eine Praxis dieser Regierung
beendet sonder eine Praxis auf Bundes
und Landesebene die von allen
politischen Akteuren verantwortet wurde
unabhängig von der parteifade und ich
will sehr selbstkritisch
sagen ein Teil der Praxis die das
Bundesverfassungsgericht geurteilt hat
hat auch diese Bundesregierung
fortgesetzt und das war im Nachhinein
ein Fehler aber die Tatsache dass das
nicht ausschließlich diese
Bundesregierung betrifft zeigt doch dass
der schlesig-holstein Ministerpräsident
Daniel Günther direkt auf dieses Urteil
regiert reagiert hat und für das
kommende Jahr und das vergangene Jahr
eine Notlage für den Landeshaushalt in
schleswiig- Holstein ausgerufen hat weil
die Jährlichkeit nicht gegeben war und
ich will sie an ihre eigene
Regierungsverantwortung und die
Haushaltsberatung ich durfte damals Teil
des Haushaltsausschusses sein Herr März
erinnern das Bundesverfassungsgericht
hat richtigerweise auch gesagt es muss
ein Sachzusammenhang bestehen zwischen
einer notlagesituation und den cheidung
des haushaltsgesetzgebers und ich
erinere mich noch sehr gut an das
Konjunkturpaket ihrer Regierungszeit bei
allem Respekt liebe Kollegin Kollegen
der Union im Nachhinein muss man doch
kritisch feststellen hatte der
stallumbau oder die nachhaltige
Waldbewirtschaftung wirklich etwas mit
der coronapandemie zu tun oder muss man
nicht im Nachhinein sagen auch das war
nicht rechtskonform diese Praxis
jedenfalls hat diese Bundesregierung nie
übernommen aus ihrer Regierungszeit
Liebe Kolleginen und Kollegen
ja wir hten die Frage der Jährlichkeit
und gerade bei Sondervermögen früher
beenden müssen das sagen wir sehr
selbstkritisch und es sind für das
laufende Haushaltsjahr Änderung
notwendig geworden der Bundeskanzler hat
das ausgeführt es sind rechtliche
Änderung und wichtig an dieser Stelle
ist dass wir am Freitag einen
Nachtragshaushalt beschließen werden um
nachträglich die richtigen und
notwendigen Strom- und gaspreisbremsen
abzusichern aber wichtig ist auch für
das Haushaltsjahr 2000
dass wir keine zusätzlichen Schulden
machen werden im Gegenteil es wird uns
mit dem Nachtragshaushalt 2023 gelingen
die Nettokreditaufnahme des Bundes um
über 40% zu senken meine Damen und
Herren das ist gute Haushaltspolitik
liebe Kollegen
Kollegen und ich will etwas zur
Schuldenbremse an der Stelle sagen weil
ja dieses Urteil hat Rechtsklarheit
geschaffen aus der wir Konsequenzen
gezogen haben für den Bundeshaus 23 und
wir werden diese auch ziehen für den
Bundeshaushalt 2024 und ich will
unumwunden einräumen mir ist bewusst
dass die Schuldenbremse im politischen
Raum unter Druck geraten ist Katharina
dröge hat das ausgeführt sie hat vor
einige Ministerpräsidenten zitiert bei
den Menschen in Deutschland ist sie nach
wie vor richtigerweise beliebt und man
kann bei der Schuldenbremse politisch
unterschiedlicher Meinung sein und ja es
gibt auch innerhalb der Koalition
unterschiedliche Auffassungen dazu aber
Herr März sich hier hinzustellen und
ernsthaft zu behaupten die unionsfamilie
sei an dieser Stelle geschlossen ist ja
wohl ein Witz schauen Sie nur auf diese
Bank und ich will erinnern an Hendrik
wüst an Daniel Günther an Kai Wegner an
Reiser haselof an Michael kretschm alle
diese
unionsministerpräsidenten haben bereits
öffentlich erklärt dass sie bereit sind
die Schuldenbremse zu schleifen der
einzige der einzige meine Damen und
Herren aus der Union der in dieser
Wochen die Schuldenbremse noch nicht in
Frage gestellt hat ist Markus Söder aber
meine Damen und Herren es ist ja auch
erst Dienstag liebe Kollegin
Kollegen ich erwarte deshalb dass der
wegruf aus Karlsruhe so wie es das
Bundeskabinett sofort entschieden hat
auch in den Bundesländern ankommt und
dass man das Urteil entsprechend eins zu
eins umsetzt und deswegen will ich an
der Stelle in aller Klarheit sagen liebe
Kollegin Kollegen weil immer wieder in
ihren Reden ohne präzise zu werden Herr
Merz ja der Eindruck entwerkt dass hier
ein anderes finanzgebahen unterwegs sei
das stimmt z.B in Bezug auf
Sondervermögen wissen Sie wie viel
Sondervermögen zu ihrer 16-jährigen
Regierungszeit gebildet worden sind es
waren 15 diese Bundesregierung schafft
fünf Sondervermögen ab wir schaffen
haushaltsklarheit und weahheit im
Gegensatz zu ihn lieber Kollege Merz im
Gegensatz zu
ihnen und ich will zum Schluss eines
sagen ja wir brauchen
Zukunftsinvestition sie sind notwendig
um unsere Wirtschaft Zukunft fest
zuumachen wir stehen zu den öffentlichen
Investition in die Infrastruktur
beispielsweise der bundesautobahnbau die
Katharina dröge angesprochen hat der
Schienenausbau und und so weiter und so
forort alles Investition der
öffentlichen Hand die unter ihnen
vernachlässigt worden sind aber aber
gleichzeitig braucht es ein Impuls für
private Investitionen in Deutschland
meine Damen und Herren um genau diese
zukunftsausgaben zu stemmen und deswegen
appelliere ich auch an der Stelle an die
staatspolitische Verantwortung der CDU
CSU ich kann nicht nachvollziehen wieso
sie aus taktischen Gründen im Bundesrat
das Wachstum chancenesetzt was unser
Land so dringen braucht aufhalten geben
Sie es endlich frei damit diese
Investitionen der Privatwirtschaft
möglich werden ich danke ihnen Christian
D von der FDP er verteidigt in seiner
Rede den Nachtragshaushalt für 2023 der
ja nun dieses diese Woche beschlossen
wurde die Schulden so rechnet er die man
dann aufnehme für
2023 seien tatsächlich weniger als man
ursprünglich geplant hätte es geht
weiter
von der Linkspartei frau Präsidentin
meine Damen und Herren lassen mich
zunächst ausdrücklich den Worten des
Bundeskanzlers bezüglich der Geiseln
anschließen und noch einmal die
Aufforderung anschließen dass die H
möglichst umgehend alle Geiseln sofort
freilässt meine Damen und Herren ich
finde richtig dass der Bundeskanzler
hier heute eine Regierungserklärung nach
Aufforderung der Opposition abgegeben
hat das war überfällig aber ich hätte
mir sowohl seitens des Kanzlers als auch
seitens der Redner der
Regierungsfraktion etwas mehr Demut
erwartet denn die Realität ist doch dass
wir eine veritable mindestens
Regierungskrise haben ich meine Herr
Scholz sie haben davon gesprochen dass
es nur
kon konturierungen gab aber ehrlich
gesagt wenn das denn so ist dann hätte
ich doch erwartet dass man mindestens
ein solches Urteil vorbereitet aber sie
waren völlig unvorbereitet auf dieses
Urteil das ist doch die Wahrheit völlig
unvorbereitet und das ist
unverantwortlich me meine Damen und
Herren die Realität ist die Realität ist
doch Deutschland hat offensichtlich ein
Fachkräfteproblem mindestens bei
Finanzministern denn es war doch Olaf
Scholz der die glorreiche Idee hatte die
nicht genutzten Coron Hilfen in den
Klima und transformationsf umzuwidmen
und Christian Lindner war es der diesen
Verfassungsbruch mit Ansage
durchgebunden hat beide beide sind
krachend gescheitert und sie tragen die
Verantwortung für die Regierungskrise
und für die Verunsicherung der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger und der
Unternehmen in diesem Land meine Damen
und Herren es ist doch es ist die
Süddeutsche Zeitung die von trickerein
gesprochen hat es ist das Handelsblatt
was von Bilanzfälschung geredet hat es
ist der Spiegel der getitelt halt Olaf
Scholz vom Absturz eines besserwisses
nein meine Damen und Herren sie sind
keine Regierung von Format sie sind
keine Regierung die Probleme löst sie
schaffen mit ihrer unseriösen Politik
Probleme so kann man die viert stärkste
Industrienation der Welt nicht regieren
meine Damen und Herren die Wahrheit
heißt doch die Notlage des des Landes
heißt Ampel aber dagegen helfen eben
nicht einmal Kredite meine Damen und
Herren liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
machen wir uns jetzt vor die
Schuldenbremse wird dieser Tage faktisch
von einem ihrer größten Fans zu Grabe
getragen nämlich von Christian Linder
habe jetzt verstanden dass Friedrich
Merz der nächste größte Fan ist in der
Union gibt's da aber offensichtlich sehr
differenzierte Auffassung dazu ich
prophezeie mal sie werden auch 2024 die
Schuldenbremse aussetzen werden müssen
vielleicht liegt das ja auch daran dass
Herr Lindner den Wald vor lauter
Schattenhaushalten nicht mehr sehen kann
bringen sie Klarheit in ihre Finanzen
beenden Sie die Kakophonie die Wahrheit
ist nur eine völlig andere das Chaos
geht doch weiter wie ist denn das mit
den energiepreisbremsen in 5 Wochen
haben wir januar und die Realität ist
Christian Linder sagt alles aus und
vorbei 5 Minuten später sagt Kevin Küh
nein die werden beibehalten ja was ist
den nur die Wahrheit wie soll dann
Unternehmerinnen und Unternehmer planen
in dieser Situation sie tragen eine
Verantwortung genauso ist das mit den
Investitionen in die schipfabriken was
ist denn da nur angesagt ich meine
Haselhoff sagt er hat mit dem Kanzler
telefoniert na Donnerwetter wenn das
ausreichend ist dann sind wir aber weit
in diesem Lande gekommen meine Damen und
Herren die Schuldenbremse ist eine
Investitionsbremse mit der
Schuldenbremse verfällt die
Infrastruktur was ist denn die Wahrheit
2009 wurde sie eingeführt und wie sind
denn jetzt wie ist denn jetzt die
Situation gibt es eine bessere Situation
bei der Bahn oder in den
Bildungseinrichtungen oder in den
Kliniken in den Straßen bei den Schienen
nichts davon wir brauchen Investition
nicht als Ausnahme sondern als Regel für
die nächsten Jahrzehnte meine Damen und
Herren ich meine Olaf Scholz hat doch
recht nur wenn sich Deutschland
modernisiert aber das sind Investitionen
doch die Voraussetzung wie soll ein Land
die gewaltigen Herausforderung der
notwendigen Transformation des
Klimaschutzes bewerkstelligen was nicht
einmal anständig investieren kann die
Schuldenbremse ist ein Anschlag auf die
Zukunft meine Damen und
Herren aber es geht natürlich nicht nur
um Investitionen sondern natürlich
geht's auch um Einnahmen und da meine
ich ausdrücklich nicht und wir meinen
ausdrücklich nicht mehr Einnahmen und
höhere Steuern etwa für die
hartarbeitende Mehrheit in diesem Land
nein im Gegenteil da müssen die
Belastung sogar runter bei steuern und
bei Strom aber es geht zum Beispiel und
das Streichen von Ausnahmen auf die
größten Erbschaften die sind die
Erbschaften je höher die Erbschaften
desto niedriger die Steuerlast also ich
meine meine Fraktion hat eine Anfrage
gestellt von den 40 Erben die über 100
Millionen 100 Millionen ich wiederhole
vererbt haben von den 40 haben 31 nicht
ein Cent Steuern gezahlt das ist doch
ein Skandal unser Land ist eine
Steueroase für Superreiche das muss man
doch beenden meine Damen und Herren das
darf nicht so bleiben
und was machen sie real real erhöhen sie
die Mehrwertsteuer sie erhöhen die
Mehrwertsteuer für die Restaurants und
nehmen damit auch eine Pleitewelle in
Kauf das ist doch das ist doch die
Wahrheit ich meine sie erhöhen auch die
Mehrwertsteuer für Schulessen z.B das S
im Übrigen ein Skandal da sollten Sie
mal auf Kommunalpolitiker von linker bis
Union hören die da eine andere Position
haben sie haben im Wahlkampf was anderes
versprochen herr Scholz und sie lassen
jetzt auch die Diskussion um
Sozialleistung laufen auch in ihrer Rede
beenden Sie das doch und sagen sie ganz
klar es wird keine sozialkürzung in
diesem Land geben das wäre so dringend
notwendig meine Damen und Herren und da
ja völlig zurecht auch die FDP dann von
Ausgabenreduzierung spricht ja
einverstanden auch darüber kann man
reden aber sie haben ja bewusst einige
Bereiche vollständig rausgenommen und
das ist natürlich zuallererst der
Rüstungsbereich das der ist
offensichtlich sakusang und das kann
doch nicht sein Verdopplung der Hilfe
für die Ukraine wird wird einfach mal so
locker zugesagt ich finde da sollte man
mal ein Fragezeichen setzen genauso wie
bei der Steigerung des verteidigungsetar
letztlich ist ihre Haushaltsplanung
Chaos pur sie setzt falsche Prioritäten
sie schont die vermögsten vermögsten das
ist die Wahrheit arbeiten sie endlich
solide als mit ungedeckten Schecks auf
Kosten der Bürgerinnen und Bürger meine
Damen und Herren herzlichen
Dank von der Linkspartei er kritisierte
unter anderem die Vielstimmigkeit der
Ampel z.B bei der energiepreisbremse und
er argumentierte klar gegen die
Schuldenbremse er nannte sie einen
Anschlag auf die Zukunft nun Mütz nicht
von der SPD Fraktion Fraktionschef der
SPD bundestagsftion Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen es gibt nichts
drum herum zueden die Entscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts ist ein
deutlicher Rückschlag und auch für mich
eine
Ernüchterung und wenn ich das sage hat
das ganze auch eine Kehrseite ich habe
es ja vielleicht noch am ersten Tag
verstanden dass Freude oder Häme hier
überwogen hat bei denjenigen die Kläger
gewesen waren aber die zweite Frage die
sich doch dann direkt angeschlossen hat
an dieses Teil war werden wir den
Herausforderungen und Notwendigkeiten
für die Zukunft mit dieser HME und mit
dieser Freude überhaupt gerecht und ich
will sagen Herr Kollege märz die
Ministerpräsidentin Ministerpräsidenten
haben es früher erkannt und
offensichtlich sie bis heute nicht ich
bedauere
das weil der Spruch der Spruch hat
Folgen für alle für den Bund für die
Länder und damit auch indirekt für die
Kommunen und er hat für die Zukunft
dieses Landes mit Sicherheit seine
Folgen wir verkennen die Probleme nicht
aber ich finde auf der anderen Seite
gehört mit dazu aus einem demokratischen
Parlament zu sagen die Demokratie die
parlamentarische Demokratie wird es
schaffen aus diesen Problemen die
richtigen Schlussfolgerungen zu ziehen
das ist etwas was wir auch den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern Schulden und
insbesondere klarzustellen das ist kein
Staatsbankrott das ist kein
haushaltsnotstand bei uns werden keine
Behörden geschlossen bei uns werden die
Gehälter weiter ausgezahlt und wir
sollten uns nicht mit den bösen
Zeitgeistern mit den sprunghaften
Zeitgeistern einen
konkurrenzwettkampf leisten die Zeiten
sind schlimm genug und deswegen will ich
durchaus sagen der Populismus an dieser
Stelle geht fehl meine Damen und
Herren
was heute von was heute von Bedeutung
ist was heute von Bedeutung ist liebe
Kolleginnen Kollegen ist nicht mehr aber
auch nicht weniger meine Fraktion hat es
gestern getan ein
Nachtragshaushalt ein Antrag für den
Deutschen Bundestag beschlossen und
gleichzeitig auch die Ausnahmeregel die
das Grundgesetz berei hält erneut zu
aktivieren und ich kann nur sagen für
meine Fraktion
wenn die Zeiten keine normalen Zeiten
sind und der Bundeskanzler hat darauf
hingewiesen welch Herausforderung dieses
Land welchen Herausforderung Europa die
Welt gegenüber steht wenn es keine
normalen Zeiten gibt dann kann es auch
keinen normalen Haushalt geben so wie
man sich das damals 2007 vorgestellt hat
ich finde schon dass wir politisch
reagieren müssen meine Damen und Herren
und es gibt
viele viele Gründe für das
Fortbestehen einer Beschreibung die eben
nicht normal ist hier ist oft der Krieg
in der Ukraine genannt worden und ich
gehe glaube ich nicht ganz fehl in der
Information dass die Bundesregierung am
11 Juni nächsten Jahres der Gastgeber
für die
wiederaufbaukonferenz für die Ukraine
sein wird einem Land was massiven
Angriffen von Seiten Russlands
ausgesetzt ist viele die dort vor Ort
sind berichten von Bildern die nicht nur
an den Ersten Weltkrieg heranreichen
sondern wahrscheinlich sogar schlimmere
Bilder sind die davon berichten dass
Städte massiv angegriffen werden und wer
wenn nicht wir die Demokratien stehen
nicht nur mit einer militärischen
Unterstützung an der Seite der Ukraine
sondern auch mit großen Leistungen was
die humanitäre Hilfe bedeutet und eben
auch für den Wiederaufbau das ist eines
der Gründe dass wir uns anstrengen
müssen in diesen nicht normalen Zeiten
auch haushaltig darauf zu reagieren und
jetzt kommt hinzu meine Damen und Herren
der Gazakrieg ja ich bin dankbar ich bin
der Bundesregierung für meine Fraktion
dankbar dass sie mit anderen Regierungen
aber insbesondere mit dem amerikanischen
Präsidenten aber auch mit dem
Generalsekretär der Vereinten Nationen
nichts unterlassen hat die Geiseln aus
der Hand der Hamas zu befreien und wer
glaubt plötzlich wird diese Situation
ganz einfach werden ich glaub der trübt
weil diejenigen die Israel vernichten
wollen schauen sich ganz genau an was
die Hamas jetzt in diesen Stunden macht
sie hat ohnehin der PLO bereits den Rang
abgelaufen was den Widerstand bedeutet
und irgendwann sind wir nicht sicher ob
nicht doch aus diesem Gazakrieg auch ein
Flächenbrand wird die ersten Dinge die
da aus dem Jemen in Richtung Israel
gegangen sind die konnten noch abgewehrt
werden aber was heißt es denn wenn die
Meerenge vor der jemenitischen Küste
geschlossen wird nicht nur für Europa
sondern auch für Asien ich schließe
daraus dass wir noch unabhängiger werden
müssen und ich glaube es gibt viele
Gründe die eben für das für diese
Ereignisse die Kontrolle des Staates
entzogen worden sind und damit auch die
staatliche Finanzlage so nicht mehr
unter Kontrolle ist und deswegen glaube
ich war es richtig gewesen mit dem
Antrag den wir in dieser in dieser Woche
in den Deutschen Bundestag einbringen
auch von Artikel 115 wieder Gebrauch zu
machen und Herr märz und liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen darauf lässt
sich argumentieren ihr Kollege der
Ministerpräsident Günther tut das frei
Weg in Schleswig-Holstein genau auf
diese Gründe bezogen und da trifft er
auf eine Opposition die ihm für die
notwendige zwei Drittel Mehrheit eben
verhilft damit diese Notlage auch
beschrieben werden kann deswegen wird
auf sie wird auf sie durchaus und
überlegen Sie es sich gut ob sie den
Menschen im ahal und wir müssen den
Artikel 100 wir müssen den Artikel
115 für die diese Hilfen ziehen
überlegen Sie gut ob Sie die Hilfen für
die Menschen im Atal in rheinernfalz und
in noch Westfalen ablehen hier im
Deutschen
Bundestag und zum
anderen und zum anderen wenn wir heute
über das
Verfassungsgerichtsurteil sprechen
sprechen wir auch über den Haushalt
2024 wir als SPD
Bundestagsfraktion haben die klare
Absicht noch in diesem Jahr auch diesen
Haushalt zu verabschieden aus zwei
Gründen und vielleicht reicht ih ja der
Eine Grund nicht für uns ist er aber
wichtig dass insbesondere die sozialen
Verbände die
unterkürzungen des Haushaltsentwurfs
gelitten haben und die in der
Bereinigungssitzung wieder korrigiert
worden sind noch in diesem Jahr
Planungssicherheit haben weil sonst
müssen sie eben Mitarbeiterin und
Mitarbeiter entlassen find das ist ein
guter Grund und zum anderen das
Budgetrecht des Parlaments ist das
vornehmste Recht des Deutschen
Bundestages vielleicht könnten auch Sie
mit überlegen ob wir uns das nicht
sichern sollten als Parlament deswegen
bitte ich dass wir den Haushalt
2024 rechtzeitig vor Ende des Jahres
abschließen uns das uns den Respekt
erweisen aber insbesondere den Menschen
draußen im Lande weil die brauchen die
Sicherheit auch aus diesem Haushalt
meine Damen und
Herren und zum anderen und das bedarf
diese Debatte finde ich auch ja und das
sagen wir schon seit Jahren wir brauchen
grundsätzliche Korrekturen an der
Gestaltung der
Schuldenbremse wir müssen uns noch
fragen ob sie angemessen ist vor den
Herausforderungen dieser Zeit die mehr
als 15 Jahre ins Land gegangen sind das
ist auch Aufgabe der Politik nicht
irgendwas sakrosand zu machen sondern
immer wieder sagen reicht es aus für die
Zukunft unseres Landes oder hat nicht
sogar die Schuldenbremse dieser
Haushaltsführung provoziert vielleicht
darf man ja diese Frage auch mal stellen
und offensichtlich leiden ja auch die
einen oder anderen Ländern da drunter
aber ich meine Damen und
Herren nurlen eine wahllos gegriffene
politische
Größe nicht als monstrans vor sich
herzuführen wenn es um die Zukunft
dieses Landes geht dieses Land hat etwas
anderes verdient nämlich in Zukunft zu
investieren und nicht meine Damen und
Herren in die Vergangenheit
ja und es ist gesagt
worden das ist nicht alles aber wir
brauchen meine Damen und Herren ein Aken
Staat andere Länder und ich will
Demokratien zitieren die dies mit
Ehrgeiz auf den Weg bringen und mit
Modernität liegen mittlerweile
meilenweit Deutschland Voraus nicht nur
in den Investition sondern dem
Gründergeist und wo sie eben auch
Industrie industrielle Kapazitäten aus
Europa abziehen die USA ist hier genannt
worden aber ich will auch Spanien nennen
Großbritannien hat erst vorgestern 5
Milliarden Euro in die batteriefertigung
investiert und deswegen will ich sehr
klar sagen ich glaube es ist richtig
auch für den nächsten Haushalt für den
mit Artikel 115 davon Gebrauch zu machen
wir brauchen meine Damen und Herren
diese
Zukunftsinvestition zum
anderen um auch mal einer
Geschichtsklitterung
vorzubeugen der Fond oder die Fonds und
mein Kollege D hat ja beschrieben wie
lange es schon mit diesen Fonds im
Bundeshaushalt ist ist nicht die
Erfindung einer Person und deswegen sage
ich auch sehr deutlich andere zum
Sündenbock zu machen werde ich nicht
akzeptieren der Staatssekretär Werner
Gatzer hat nicht mehr aber auch nicht
weniger gemacht als das was politisch
wollt ist meine Damen und Herren
technisch umzusetzen ich finde ich finde
das gehört zur Wahrheit mit dazu und zum
anderen wenn wir schon über diese
Geschichte reden dann will ich auch hier
gegenüber der Öffentlichkeit sagen ich
zumindestens kann mich gut daran
erinnern dass in den Haushalts in in den
Koalitionsverhandlungen gerade vor dem
Hintergrund des hässischen
Verfassungsgerichtsurteils genau über
diese Schritte gesprochen worden sind
und ich finde politische Verantwortung
gibt man nicht am Kleiderhaken auf
sondern dazu steht man meine Damen und
Herren und deswegen sage ich es auch
noch mal dies zumindestens vielleicht
interessiert hier wird ja vieles ganz
schwarz an die Wand gemalt was mit
diesem Land mit Deutschland verbunden
ist wir sind das Land was in Europa mit
die geringste Schuldenquote hat 62
20% unter dem Durchschnitt der der
europäischen Länder
30% unter dem der Euroländer ich finde
schon das müssen sie akzeptieren zahlen
lügen einfach nicht da können sie sich
nicht gegen wen und deswegen ich glaube
dass in dieser Situation etwas
vertretbar ist aber damit es Ihnen
vielleicht noch besser gefällt und damit
auch die politische Auseinandersetzung
endlich mal in diesem Parlament zwischen
uns auch klar wird es geht nicht um
verfassungstechnische Fragen sondern es
geht darum Verteilungsfragen auch in
diesem Land immer wieder zu adressieren
deswegen sage ich auch klar ja wir
müssen über ein verfassungsgemäßen
Haushalt reden aber auf der anderen
Seite auch über unverdienten Reichtum in
diesem Land und wir SozialdemokratInnen
Sozialdemokraten werden in einer Woche
auf dem Bundesparteitag genau
tigwen auf diesen Herausforderung geben
meine Damen und Herren es ist kein
Zweifel es ist kein Zweifel wir werden
dieses Urteil umsetzen ich habe Respekt
vor dem Bundesverfassungsgericht aber
ich will auch gleichzeitig sagen ich
hoffe auch dass das
Bundesverfassungsgericht vor anderen
verfassungsinstitutionen wie de
Deutschen Bundestag auch Respekt hat
deswegen finde ich wenn mans gegenseitig
Respekt erlaubt kann man über das eine
oder andere auch diskutieren ich bin mir
unsicher ob die kameralistische und
strenge Auslegung von Jährlichkeit und
jährigkeit wirklich den
Herausforderungen gerecht wird meine
Damen und Herren jeder Investor jeder
Investor in diesem Land plant glaube ich
länger als ein Jahr soziale Verbände
sind darauf angewiesen dass ihre Arbeit
länger als ein Jahr Dauer und schon gar
nicht Naturkatastrophen halten sich an
die jährlich und jährigkeit sondern sie
undter zeigt ja z.B das atteil was diese
Herausforderungen sind deswegen will ich
sagen manche Argumentation erserschließt
sich mir nicht und insbesondere die
haushaltsverfassungsrechtliche Dogmatik
in Übereinstimmung mit einem
Richterspruch zu bringen der uns vor
einigen Jahren den Klimaschutz als
Verfassungsrang definiert hat hätte ich
mir von die diesem Teil meine Damen und
Herren schon erwartet und das 2007
dasselbe Bundesverfassungsgericht uns
auch Anleitung zur Schuldenbremse
gegeben hat das ist ja auch Teil der
Wahrheit aber was mir am meisten
aufgestoßen ist und ich finde das gehört
zu einer öffentlichen Debatte dazu
einmal kann das passieren wenn man sich
einen langfristigen Zeitplan gibt damals
als es um das Gebäude Energiegesetz ging
und als wir es kurz vor der Sommerpause
im Interesse der men
hier abschließend lesen wollen gab es
das Teil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes auch jetzt
wieder ein Tag vor der
Bereinigungssitzung mit diesem Urteil zu
konfrontiert zu werden provoziert auch
manche Diskussion auch in meinen rein
und auch das meine Damen und Herren
müssen die Richterinnen und Richter
wissen deswegen zum Schluss ich habe ich
hab ich hab ich hab ich habe den Respekt
gen Verfassungsgericht geäußert aber ich
will auch sagen ich glaube auch dass der
Deutsche Bundestag Respekt verlangt
meine Damen und Herren der Haushalt
2024 sollte rechtzeitig beschlossen
werden ich finde in der
Bereinigungssitzung ist Beachtliches
geleistet worden darüber wird
hoffentlich in den kommenden Wochen noch
im Deutschen Bundestag ausreichend
gesprochen werden aber ich will einen
Punkt herausgreifen den der Kinder und
Jugendpolitik der Kinder und jugendplan
ist verbessert worden die
Elterngeldregelung ist verbessert worden
wir haben Mittel für die barfkreform auf
den Weg gebracht aber was mir ganz
wichtig war dass auch die Förderung des
Sports für junge Menschen mit
Behinderung Eingang in diesen Haushalt
gefunden hat und da will ich ganz klar
sagen weil wir reden manchmal über
verfassungstechnik für die
Haushaltsführung hier konkret um junge
Menschen mit Behinderung und das meine
Damen und Herren ist die haushalterische
Antwort auf ein Skandal der leider viel
zu schnell vergessen worden ist der vom
chefpropagandisten der AFD von Herrn
höcke im Sommer diesen Jahres in die
Welt gebracht worden ist dass nämlich
junge Menschen mit Behinderung die
geboren sind oder durch einen Unfall
diese Behinderung davon tragen oder
durch Krankheit eine Belastung für diese
Gesellschaft sind was für ein Skandal
meine Damen und Herren und deswegen sage
ich hinter einem Haushalt hinter einem
Haushalt stehen auch politische
Antworten und deswegen sage ich auch
denen die da meinen und das spreche ich
niemandem ab die Wahl ist frei aber wer
sich den Luxus leistet eine solche
Partei in die Macht zu
der muss sich nicht wundern dass es
nicht nur bei diesen Kindern und
Jugendlichen bleibt sondern dann sind
die Kranken dran dann sind die
Rentnerinnen und Rentner dran dann sind
die Menschen die so fühlen auch so leben
wollen dran das ist die Konsequenz und
das ist auch in einer
Haushaltsdebatte erforderlich meine
Damen und Herren deswegen sage ich ohne
soziale Gerechtigkeit und Anstand kann
man eine freiheitliche Demokratie nicht
bestehen
deshalbiden sagen nicht allein über ein
angepasstes Budget od über dessen
verfassungsrechtliche vorauss es geht
nicht allein um finanztechnische Fragen
in diesen Tagen entscheiden wir auch
über ein verlässliches Maß an sozialer
Gerechtigkeit für Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer deren Familien junge
Menschen Kranke wir entscheiden über die
Bollwerke einer lebensfähigen sozialen
Demokratie meine Damen und Herren vielen
Dank Rolf mitzinig Fraktionschef der
Bundestagsfraktion der SPD er
verteidigte die nachträgliche
rückwirkende Ausrufung einer Notlage für
das Jahr
2023 um entsprechend auch für 2023
nochmals die Schuldenbremse auszusetzen
denn so argumentierte er es seien nach
wie vor keine normalen Zeiten als
Beispiel führte er an den andauernden
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine und den
nun neu gestarteten Krieg im
Gazastreifen als nächstes hören wir
Alexander Dobrind wir sehen ihn schon im
Bild von der
CSU als nächstes hat das Wort für die
CDU CSU Fraktion Alexander
dobrin
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und
Kollegen politische Verantwortung gibt
man nicht am Kleiderhaken ab dazu steht
man Herr Mütze nicht das waren ihre
Worte gerade genau das hätten wir heute
an diesem Rednerpult erwartet es gab
kein Wort das bedauern es gab keine
Entschuldigung dieser ampelregierung
meine Damen und
Herren
Herr Bundeskanzler sie haben heute dem
Deutschen Bundestag und der
Öffentlichkeit mitgeteilt dass die
Anwendungsregeln der Schuldenbremse vor
diesem
Verfassungsgerichtsurteil nicht wirklich
bekannt gewesen wären sie haben weiter
der Öffentlichkeit und im Bundestag
mitgeteilt dass das Verfassungsgericht
über eine
Staatspraxis geurteilt hätte und sie
haben ferner Herr Mütz auch noch die
Dreistigkeit besessen davon zu reden
dass die Schuldenbremse vielleicht sogar
diesen Betrug provoziert hätte ich will
ihnen sagen wie die Realität an dieser
Stelle ist diese Worte diese Worte von
ihnen Staatspraxis nicht bekannt wie die
Schuldenbremse wirkt und dann auch noch
zu behaupten dass es vielleicht die
Grundlage für den Betrug ist das zeigt
die ganze Arroganz und Respektlosigkeit
wie sie mit diesem Urteil umgehen
es war ihre ampelregierung Herr
Bundeskanzler die Sie zu verantworten
haben die sich Milliarden
vorratsschulden in den Keller gelegt hat
die sich nach Belieben über Zeitpunkt
und Zweck der Ausgaben dieser
schuldengelder selber entscheiden wollte
und die alle Welt glauben machen wollte
dass sie die Schuldenbremse ein halten
obwohl jetzt klar ist mit dem
nachtagshaushalt dass sie 45 Milliarden
über die Schuldenbremse ausgegeben haben
und deswegen hat die Süddeutsche
natürlich recht wenn sie am Wochenende
titelt die Tricker das ist das Prädikat
ihrer Ampel und ich sage es sind nicht
nur Tricker sondern es ist schlichtweg
der Betrug an der Schuldenbremse der
hier begangen worden
ist und jetzt haben wir heute wieder
gehört dass wie ein Mantra das ständig
vor sich hergragen wird dass es ja auch
in der Vorgängerregierung schon einen V
mit überjährigkeit gegeben hat der in
den Haushalt eingestellt worden ist was
sie dabei was sie dabei aber
verschweigen ist erstens dass dieser V
hatte nicht ihre buchungstricks um die
Schuldenbremse zu übergehen und zweitens
dass der
Bundesfinanzminister zu diesem Zeitpunkt
Olaf Scholz geheißen hat und deswegen
hat das Verfassungsgericht nicht über
eine Staatspraxis entschieden sondern
das hat über das System Olaf Scholz
entschieden und es auser Kraft
gesetzt sie haben dabei übrigens alle
Warnungen außer Acht gelassen alle
Warnungen die auch jetzt in den letzten
Tagen ja wiederholt worden sind der
öniche Berater des Finanzministers
Professor Lars Feld hat es noch mal
deutlich gesagt wörtlich zitiert trotz
der Bedenken im
Bundesfinanzministerium vor und nach dem
amtsbeginn der Bundesregierung kam es zu
dieser Entscheidung der Stabilitätsrat
hat sie explizit damals darauf
hingewiesen wörtlich zitiert damit droht
dass das verfassungsrechtliche Ziel der
Schuldenbremse faktisch ausgehölt wird
Warnungen gab es genug
sie wollten sie ignorieren sie wollten
sie schlichtweg ignorieren und auch das
sagt das Urteil es ist schlichtweg die
Arroganz die sie am Schluss dazu
gebracht hat dass sie die Verfassung
gebrochen haben meine Damen und
Herren und Herr Bundeskanzler sie haben
heute mit keinem Wort erwähnt wie unsere
europäischen Nachbarn über diese
Finanzkrise in Deutschland denken die
Menschen allerdings haben einen sehr
klaren Eindruck davon bekommen was sich
in unserem Land verändert hat dass beim
Besuch der italienischen
Ministerpräsidentin hier in Berlin bei
ihrem gemeinsamen Auftritt die
italienische Ministerpräsidentin von
Journalisten gefragt wird im Bezug auf
ihre Finanzfragen ob da Deutschland noch
ein verlässlicher Partner ist das hätten
sich die Menschen in unserem Land
niemals vorstellen können das berührt
die Menschen und das meine Damen zeigt
die ganze Verzweiflung in der Sie diese
Bundesregierung gebracht
haben in Europa werden aktuell die
Verhandlungen über einen gemeinsamen
Haushalt geführt der Stabilitäts und
Wachstumspakt der wird auch neu
verhandelt werden die Akzeptanz über das
Einhalten von Regeln spielt dabei eine
ganz entscheidende Rolle und wir haben
das in der Vergangenheit schon mal
erlebt denken sie zurück an die
eurofinanzkrise was wir da erlebt haben
die
Finanzstabilität und Solidität
Deutschlands die hat die gemeinsame
Währung zusammengehalten Deutschland war
es die den Euro am Schluss gerettet
haben wenn die Haushaltsregeln in
Deutschland nicht mehr eingehalten
werden dann wird es schwer in Europa und
unsere Partner zur
Haushaltsdisziplin zu bewegen das heißt
Herr Bundeskanzler mit ihrer Politik
gefährden sie die Finanzstabilität in
Europa das ist die
Wahrheit ich hätte heute übrigens
erwartet dass sie ein klares Bekenntnis
abgeben der Bundeskanzler dass sie die
Schuldenbremse 2024 einhalten wollen ich
hätte dieses K Bekenntnis erwartet weil
es ein paar andere verstörende
Wortmeldungen der hier gegeben hat Herr
Mützen nicht ich habe se ja genau
aufgepasst sie haben mehrfach die
Ukraine in ihrer Rede erwähnt sie haben
mehrfach von unnormalen Zeiten
gesprochen das ist doch nichts anderes
als dass sie vorbereiten wollen dass
204 die Schuldenbremse auch nicht mehr
eingehalten wird und ich will ihn damit
auf die Reise geben bei ihren Beratungen
wir werden auf absehbare Zeit keine
normalen Zeiten mehr erleben wer das als
Ausrede nimmt der wird nie wieder zu
soliden Haushalten zurückführen meine
Damen und
Herren und anstatt dass sie den
Bundestag und der Öffentlichkeit
mitteilen wie sie die Schuldenbremse
2024 einhalten können sind weite Teile
ihrer Koalition jeden Tag damit
beschäftigt darüber zu diskutieren wie
man die Schuldenbremse abschaffen kann
oder wie man die Schuldenbremse
aufweichen kann das ist schlichtweg kein
Bekenntnis zum Einhalten der
Schuldenbremse und der Regeln wir haben
am Parteitag wir haben am Parteitag der
Grünen Herrn habeg auch sehr genau
zugehört der formuliert hat mit der
Schuldenbremse ein Zitat mit der
Schuldenbremse haben wir uns freiwillig
die Hände auf den Rücken gefesselt und
ziehen in einen Boxkampf nur mal hier zu
den Fakten in diesem Jahr
2023 ist es möglich mit Einhalten der
Schuldenbremse legal über 40 Milliarden
Euro neue Schulden zu machen im nächsten
Jahr ist es legal beim Einhalten der
Schuldenbremse möglich über 20
Milliarden neue Schulden zu machen sie
wollen einfach nicht mit diesem Geld
zurechtkommen für sie reicht dieses Geld
schlichtweg einfach nicht aus und
deswegen sage ich Ihnen Herr habbeck die
Ampel ist doch kein Boxer dem man die
Hände gefesselt hat die Ampel ist ein
schuldensüchtiger dem bei der
Beschaffungskriminalität entdeckt und
erwischt
hat wissen Sie die Schuldenbremse wurde
doch genau deswegen eingeführt um so
eine Politik zu verhindern die
Schuldenbremse wurde doch genau deswegen
eingeführt um vorzubeugen dass Politik
ausschließlich auf Kosten der kommenden
Generation gemacht worden ist die Schuld
gemacht wird die Schuldenbremse soll
doch schlichtweg verhindern dass
die Ausgaben ins Uferlose wachsen sie
soll disziplinieren das ist doch
schlichtweg die Aufgabe der
Schuldenbremse und deswegen sage ich
Ihnen auch an dieser Stelle sie können
mit uns selbstverständlich darüber reden
wie man solide Haushalte aufstellt aber
wir reichen keine Hand dafür unsolides
Haushalten in dieser Bundesregierung zum
Dauerbeschäftigung zu machen wir geben
ihnen nicht die Hand dafür dass die
abschaffen der Schuldenbremse
legalisiert wird dafür haben sie nicht
unsere
Unterstützung
so wir waren jetzt auch überrascht zu
hören dass Sie Herr mützenig den
Haushalt
2024 noch in diesem Jahr beraten wollen
es hat gestern ein Schreiben des
bundesfanzministers der hat in diesem
Schreiben an alle Kolleginnen und
Kollegen darauf hingewiesen dass er den
Haushalt 24 gemeinsam mit dem Haushalt
25 beraten will das riecht nicht danach
dass das in diesem Jahr noch stattfinden
kann möglicherweise sind auch Sie hier
nicht einig und möglicherweise sind sie
auch hier nicht in der Lage eine
gemeinsame Linie zu finden ich kann ihn
an der Stelle nur sagen das was der
Bundesfinanzminister in der letzten
Debatte hier formuliert hat Bildung
Sicherheit
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit wörtliches Zitat
all das ist möglich bei den bestehenden
Einnahmen ohne Flucht in neue Schulden
oder höhere Steuern Herr
Bundesfinanzminister wir nehmen sie sch
hier beim Wort dieses Land hat kein
Einnahmeproblem es hat schlichtweg ein
ausgabeproblem das heißt setzen sie
endlich setzen Sie den Sparstift an
dieses Land braucht schlichtweg kein
heizungsgesetz das dem Staat und Bürger
Milliarden kostet es braucht keine 5000
neuen sacharbeiterstellen um die
Kindergrundsicherung auszubezahlen und
es braucht kein Bürgergeld dass die
Menschen die Sozialhilfe treibt und
nicht in die Arbeit integriert das
braucht dieses Land
nicht und sehr ge der
Bundeskanzler dass sie das Wort des
Bedauerns und der Entschuldigung hier
nicht in der Lage waren gegenüber der
Öffentlichkeit und dem Bundestag zum
Ausdruck zu bringen das empfinde ich
schlichtweg als nicht angemessen ich
empfinde das nicht als angemessen und
ich kann ihn sagen dieses Land braucht
Führung und keine Phrasen zeigen sie
Führung und beenden sie endlich dieses
ampeldrama herzlichen
Dank erneut eine aggressive Rede von
Alexander Dobrind von der CSU er
wiederholte eben zum Ende der Rede
nochmals dass er eine Entschuldigung von
Kanzler Scholz in dessen
Regierungserklärung vermisst hab für die
Fraktion
bündes Kindler Haushälter aus der
Fraktion aus der Bundestagsfraktion der
Grünen sehrrte frau Präsidentin liebe
Kollegin und Kollegen das war ein
schönes schlussf her dr das Land brauch
Führung keine Phrasen das hat ihre Rede
sehr gut ausgezeichnet und
zusammengefasst und ich hätte mir auch
ein bisschen mehr Demut gewünscht wenn
ich ihr rede gehört habe angesichts der
Maut die Sie beschlossen haben aber das
ist vielleicht sfrage die UN von i
unscheidet Herz Herr märzt ich wollte
was zu ihrer Rede sagen sie haben sich
als Mann der 90er Jahre geautet jetzt
gehen sie nach hinten aber ich wollte
trotzdem noch noch mal
eingehen ich finde ja gut dass sie dazu
stehen dass sie ein Mann der 90er Jahre
sind ich find es gut wenn man nicht
selbst steht wollte darauf hinweisen dar
hat auch der FDP Kollege schon
hingwiesen Herr dur ich bin sehr froh
dass der heutige Wirtschaftsminister
Robert habbeck heißt und nicht Jürgen
Möllemann um das klar zu sagen se hart
für die FDP aber ich glaube da gibt's
einen breiten konsetz in diesem Haus m
und
in den 90er Jahren Herr März waren sie
schon im Bundestag ich war in der
Grundschule aber ich habe damals schon
aufgepasst wie die finanzpolitischen
Rahmendaten waren und ich will sie noch
mal erinnern wie das war Theo Weigel war
Finanzminister die Staatsschulden in
Deutschland 600 Milliarden 600
Milliarden Deutsche Mark DMark auf 1,45
Milliarden DMark gestiegen 850
Milliarden DMark die staatschonen von
1990 bis 1998 gestiegen es gab eine
Vermögenssteuer noch in Deutschland in
den 90er Jahren die Weige sogar erhöht
es gab ein Solidaritätsbeitrag der
spitzensteuersagt lag be
lag bei 53% und die Schuldenbremse war
nicht im Grundgesetz ich finde spannend
dass sie diesen finanzpolitischen
Rahmendaten orientieren wollen dass das
Vorbild nehmen ich bin gespannt ob wir
Initiativen dazu in der nächsten Zeit
her
märz und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
das bundesverfassungsricht hat uns einen
klaren Auftrag gegeben und ich will hier
sehr klar sagen das war ein Fehler der
zweite nachagshaushalt 21 darum kann man
nicht drum rum ren und gleichzeitig hat
es aber massive Auswirkungen für die
Staatshaushalte in Bund und Ländern
aktuell hat gerade reiner Haselhoff per
Deutsche Presseagentur erklärt dass ihr
Sondervermögen dass S in Corona
aufgenommen haben mit notlagenkrediten
dafür 2023 und 204 die Notlage erklären
werden genauso macht es Daniel Günther
CDU Ministerpräsident in
schlesäig-holstein der Landtag hat es
beschlossen 2023 2024 die Notlage
erklärt das heißt wir haben noch eine
gemeinsame Verantwortung jetzt auf
Grundlage dieses Urteils darf nicht weg
muss der Verantwortung auch stehen als
Union und ich glaube das unterscheidet
eben Friedrich März und die
Oppositionsfraktion der Union hier im
Deutschen Bundestag von den
Regierungspolitikern die im
Verantwortung stehen die CDU
Ministerpräsidenten und andere Politiker
in Verantwortung müssen sich im konkrete
Gedanken machen wie wir zukünftig
Haushalte aufstellen das machen Kai
Wegner das machen reiner Haselhoff das
macht Michael kretschm das macht Hendrik
wüst die ja alle darüber gesprochen
haben dass sie ein Modernisierungsbedarf
bei der Schuldenbremse sehen weil sie
sich die Frage stellen wie können wir in
Zukunft eigentlich noch Investitionen
finanzieren oder nach diesem
Urteil und es ist stellt sich eben die
Frage wie können wir jetzt das hilft der
nächsten Generation noch nichts wenn dur
Schulen durch die deckeropft hilft der
nächsten Generation nichts wenn die
Infrastruktur verrottet wenn
Eisenbahnbrücken gesperrt werden müssen
nicht mehrfahren werden können es hilft
der nächsten Generation nichts wenn die
klimaneutrale Transformation der
Wirtschaft jetzt gestoppt wird und
deswegen müssen wir darüber reden wie
wir diese Investition in Zukunft
finanzieren können und Wirtschaft
wirtschaftspolitisch wä es auch sinnvoll
sich ein Unternehmen zu investieren
jedes große jedes kleine jedes
mittelständis Unternehmen finanziert
Investitionen nicht nur aus Eigenkapital
nicht nur aus laufenden Einnahmen sie
Finanzier Fremdkapital anders gesagt
über Kredite über Schulden weil es eben
nachhaltige Investitionen geht so
werthaltige Investitionen geht die neues
Vermögen schaffen deswegen machen das
Unternehmen wir müssen über reden wie
wir im Rahmen der Schuldenbremse die wir
nicht abschaffen wollen aber die wir
erweitern wollen die wir öffnen wollen
für Investitionen jetzt wieder
freuen uns auf Vorschläge aus der CDU
wir fre auf CDU
Ministerpräsidenten und ich will jetzt
klar sagen es geht beim den 60
Milliarden jetzt im KTF geht es um
Klimaschutz es geht um die Einhaltung
von Gesetzen es geht die Einhaltung von
Abkommen das völkerrechliche Pariser
Klimaabkommen es geht um das
Klimaschutzgesetz und es geht Kern der
Generation Gerechtigkeit dass unsere
Kinder unsere Enkel noch eine Zukunft
wie sie Planeten haben darum geht es
beim klimatrans
[Applaus]
aber es geht gleichzeitig auch darum bei
den 60 Milliarden Euro um die Zukunft
der deutschen Wirtschaft es geht darum
wie wir Grünen Stahl schaffen können wie
wir die Chemieindustrie umbauen können
wie wir die Zementindustrie umbauen
können es geht darum dass
solarproduktion es geht um die
windkraftproduktion nicht nur in USA und
China stattfindet sondern dass sie in
Deutschland stattfindet es geht darum
dass batteriezellenproduktion in
Deutschland in schlißig heutstein
stattfindet es geht darum dass die
Gebäudesanierung organisieren und
finanzieren es geht um die
mobilitätswende und zwar überall in
Deutschland in Sachsen SachsenAnhalt in
Brandenburg in schlesighutchland im
Saarland in Bremen NW überall es geht um
10000 100ta000 Arbeitsplätze die wir
nicht gefährden dürfen und deswegen
haben wir eine gemeinsame Verantwortung
das jetzt langfristig zu finanzieren
diese gemeinsame Verantwortung haben wir
alle die Bundesregierung die Koalition
hier im Parlament die demokratische
Opposition und die Landesregierung diese
gemeinsame Verantwortung müssen wir
jetzt annehmen
danke Kindler von der grünen
Bundestagsfraktion und an dieser Stelle
blenden wir uns aus der Debatte nach der
Regierungserklärung von Kanzler Scholz
aus eine Debatte die geprägt war von häe
und persönlichen aggressiven Angriffen
aber eher nicht von konstruktiven
Lösungsideen wie man die 60 Milliarden
Finanzlücke schließen kann ein letztes
Mal geben wir ab zu meiner Kollegin
Andrea Maurer vor dem Plenum steht sie
und von dir Andrea hätte ich gerne
deinen Eindruck hat denn der Kanzler
geliefert z.B Selbstkritik oder
Lösungsideen ja
er hat es nicht würde ich sagen und es
ist schon erstaunlich dass er die
Erwartungen die im Vorfeld an seine Rede
gestellt wurden da war ja die presselage
auch klar die Forderungen standen im
Raum dass er da diese Erwartung gar
nicht mit seiner Rede abgeglichen hat es
war ja auch klar dass Selbstkritik von
ihm erwartet wird aber Olaf Scholz ist
sich im Grunde genommen treu geblieben
es war eine Rede im Stil Olaf Scholz er
hat fast alles richtig gemacht er lässt
sich nicht treiben zum Haushalt 2024 der
Frage aller Fragen hat er nichts gesagt
das ist ein politisch zu heikles Thema
und so wird wohl heute auch diese Rede
nicht in die historischen
Regierungserklärungen eingehen es war
keine Rede im Stil der zeitenwenderede
die er hier im Parlament im nachklpp zu
dem Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine
gehalten hat dank dir sehr Andrea Maurer
für diese erste schnelle Einordnung das
war's von uns die Regierungserklärung
des Kanzlers zum Haushalt der dieses
Jahr eine Zerreißprobe für die Ampel ist
wir danken für Ihr Interesse hier geht's
weiter mit den 12 Uhr heute Nachrichten
tschüss und auf Wiedersehen